Brought to you by the Every Dollar app. Start budgeting for free today. Normal is broke. Common sense is weird. So we're here to help you transform your life from the Ramsey Network and the Fairwinds Credit Union Studio. This is the Ramsey Show. I'm Dave Ramsey, your host, Dr. John Deloney.
本节目由 Every Dollar 应用程序为您呈现。今天就开始免费制定预算吧。正常就是破产，常识就是怪异。所以我们来自 Ramsey Network 和 Fairwinds Credit Union 工作室，旨在帮助您改变生活。这是 Ramsey 秀。我是主持人 Dave Ramsey，这是我的联合主持人 John Deloney 博士。
Ramsey Personality, number one best-selling author, host of the Dr. John Deloney show, is my co-host today. Open phones here at AAA 8255-225. Ryan is in Wake Forest, North Carolina. Hey, Ryan, what's up? Hi, Dave. How are you doing today?
Ramsey 专家、畅销书作家、《John Deloney 博士秀》主持人，今天担任我的联合主持人。热线电话已开通，号码是 888-825-5225。Ryan 在北卡罗来纳州的威克森林。嘿，Ryan，你好吗？嘿，Dave。你今天怎么样？
Better than I deserve. What's up? Amen. Well, I'm calling because I'm a single mom of two, and I also take care of my mom. And my question today is about how do I manage paying off debt while I'm still incurring medical expenses from both her. And I also have a daughter who was hospitalized, and she's got ongoing medical care that needed as well. Okay. So you have health insurance, I assume. I have health insurance, but we have and yes, and we've come, we've mixed out the deductible and we're getting close to maxing out
比我应得的要好。怎么了？阿门。嗯，我打电话是因为我是两个孩子的单亲妈妈，还要照顾我的母亲。我今天的问题是，在还要承担她和我的医疗费用的同时，我该如何偿还债务？我还有一个女儿曾住院治疗，她也需要持续的医疗护理。好的。我想你有医疗保险吧？我有医疗保险，但是我们已经达到了免赔额，而且快要达到
the out-of-pocket expenses as well too, but even that, the deductible is high because we have a high deductible insurance plan. Okay. Okay. And, and, And so what do you make a year? Well, in total 160. Okay. And how high is your deductible? It's $5,000. And what's your max out of pocket?
自付额的上限了，即便如此，由于我们购买的是高免赔额保险计划，免赔额还是很高的。好的。好的。那么你一年的收入是多少？总共 16 万。好的。你的免赔额是多少？5000 美元。你的自付额上限是多少？
Another $4,000. Okay. So $9,000 does not break you if you make $160. I'm confused. It doesn't break me, but I'm also, I've got other expenses that I'm trying to pay off as well. Okay. There's not pay, you don't pay all. I mean, if you have medical bills that are ongoing,
另外 4000 美元。好的。所以如果你有 16 万的收入，9000 美元并不会让你破产。我很困惑。它不会让我破产，但我还有其他债务需要偿还。好的。不是说不还，我的意思是，如果你有持续的医疗账单，
that exceed the 9,000, what would they be? That exceed the 9,000, it would be, well, so for my daughter, she's, I don't want to say too much, but she's got medical expenses that are going to be ongoing for the unfeasurable future. So she's got a chronic, she's got a chronic issue of some kind? Yes. Okay, but above the 9,000, do you come out of pocket for that situation? I'm sure because it's all fairly new. Well, it shouldn't be.
超过了 9000 美元，那会是什么情况？如果超过了 9000 美元，嗯，对于我女儿来说，我不想说太多，但她的医疗费用在可预见的未来将是持续性的。所以她有某种慢性病吗？是的。好的，但在 9000 美元之外，你需要自己掏腰包吗？我肯定需要，因为这都是相当新的情况。嗯，不应该这样。
So there's some things that they cover and some things that they don't. Unless you're trying to get a treatment that your insurance company doesn't cover, the $9,000 should be the end of it. Now, okay, so you keep, I'm a little bit confused with the way you're using the words on pay off your bills. You pay your monthly bills. You pay your electricity. You pay your water. You buy food. I'm sorry.
有些项目他们承保，有些则不承保。除非你试图进行保险公司不承保的治疗，否则 9000 美元应该是上限。好吧，我有点困惑你所说的“偿还账单”的意思。你支付每月的账单。你支付电费。你支付水费。你购买食物。抱歉。
Yeah. You buy food. Yeah, sorry. I should have said debt. Okay. And then how much debt do you have? So I've got 20K and a car and 3K on a credit card and then 190 mortgage. Okay, good, good.
是的。你购买食物。是的，抱歉。我应该说债务。好的。那么你有多少债务？我有 2 万美元的车贷，3000 美元的信用卡债务，还有 19 万的抵押贷款。好的，很好。
None of that's out of line. And part of that is, yeah, and part of that is an 80 loan. So about 55 of that 190 is the AT loan. You mean like a second, like an HO, a home equity loan? Home equity. Okay. Okay. All right.
这些都在正常范围内。其中一部分是，是的，其中一部分是房屋净值贷款。你是说像第二抵押贷款，即房屋净值贷款吗？房屋净值贷款。好的。好的。
And so you've got two house payments, a car payment and some credit cards, and you've got some ongoing medical bills with your daughter's chronic issues, and you make $160. Right. Okay. And then there's my mother as well. Okay. And what are you having to pay for her? Personal, so nurse, so she's got several comorbidities, and so,
所以你有两笔房贷、一笔车贷和一些信用卡债务，还有女儿慢性病带来的持续医疗账单，而你的年收入是 16 万。对。好的。还有我母亲的情况。好的。你必须为她支付什么费用？私人护理，她有几种合并症，所以，
we're trying to pay a nurse to help take care of her. And does she have income coming in to this situation? She's got Social Security, but it's not a lot. Like $1,500, $1,500, what? Yeah, somewhere around this. Okay, and what's the nurse cost? About 25 to, well, depending on how much experience they have, $25 and up, an hour. Okay, but I mean, in a month, what are you spending on a nurse?
我们正在努力支付护士费用来帮助照顾她。她有收入来源吗？她有社会保障金，但不多。大约 1500 美元，1500 美元什么？是的，差不多这个数。好的，护士费用是多少？大约 25 美元或以上，取决于他们的经验。好的，我是说，一个月你在护士身上花多少钱？
So we haven't, we just kind of do some part time for now. Okay, and what are you spending on a nurse in a month? So about a thousand. And your mom brings in 1,200. Mm-hmm. Okay, so we covered that. But it will go up, yeah. Yeah, well, but I mean, for now, that's covered.
我们目前只是做一些兼职。好的，你一个月在护士身上花多少钱？大约一千美元。你母亲有 1200 美元的收入。嗯。好的，所以这部分覆盖了。但费用会增加的。是的，但目前来说，这部分是覆盖了的。
In the last two months, you're trying to figure out why you weren't paying your bills, able to pay your bills, and that's pay extra on your debt, and that's what I'm trying to figure out by asking all these questions, where it's going. Okay. because I still hadn't found where it's going. So it sounds like that you are a warrior princess working very hard, and you've got the emotional drain of your mom not doing well and your child with a chronic illness.
在过去的两个月里，你一直在试图弄清楚为什么你无法支付账单，无法在偿还债务上多付钱，这就是我通过问这些问题试图弄清楚的地方，钱都去哪了。好的。因为我还没找到钱去哪了。听起来你是一位非常努力的“战士公主”，你承受着母亲健康状况不佳和孩子患有慢性病的双重情感压力。
And because you're not running with a full gas tank, it's hard for you to not let all this just become chaotic. And so the bills in an emotional bucket, the bills have been, become chaos instead of if you didn't have all this other stuff you were carrying, you're obviously a bright woman. You would just sit down and make a list of this and start paying it because the math tells me that this is doable. But I think what's happening is you're just overwhelmed. Does that sound right? That's true. That's true. I am overwhelmed. But it's more than that. It's that I feel like because I was in baby step number four and now I feel like I'm probably
因为你没有满油运行，很难不让这一切变得混乱。所以账单在情感层面变成了混乱，而不是如果你没有背负这些其他负担，你显然是一位聪明的女性。你会坐下来列个清单并开始偿还，因为数学告诉我这是可行的。但我认为发生的情况是你被压垮了。听起来对吗？是真的。是真的。我确实被压垮了。但不仅如此。我觉得因为我之前处于“小步计划”第四步，现在我觉得我可能
back to baby step number two because of the debt that keeps in. No, you went and bought a car and put yourself in Baby Step 2. Well, no, I had to buy a card and you used it. Yeah, because I had to buy one because there were a lot of other expenses that had, you know, unforeseeable, unfortunate expenses that came up. You got a lot of half-toes in your life, go. Well, I mean, it was an H-FAC system that went out in the car. I had another car, but it had over 250,000 miles on it, and I had just spent $3,000 to get it fixed,
又回到了第二步，因为债务不断增加。不，是你去买了车，把自己放回了第二步。嗯，不，我必须买车，你用了它。是的，因为我必须买一辆，因为有很多其他不可预见的、不幸的开支出现了。你的生活中有很多“不得不”，继续。嗯，我的意思是，暖通空调系统坏了，车也坏了。我有另一辆车，但它已经跑了超过 25 万英里，我刚花了 3000 美元修理它，
and now it needs another 3,000. But you made the decision, put yourself back in this mess. You're giving me all the reasons, but you still did it. Don't hear ownership as a character judgment or some sort of moral failure. It's owning I took step A, B, and the world happened to me, and I chose this path, not this path. And it hurts. And it hurts. Yeah.
现在又需要 3000 美元。但这是你做的决定，让自己回到了这个烂摊子。你给了我所有的理由，但你还是这么做了。不要把“承担责任”听成是对人格的评判或某种道德失败。这是承认我采取了 A、B 步骤，世界发生在我身上，我选择了这条路，而不是那条路。这很痛苦。这很痛苦。是的。
And sometimes you find yourself at a crossroads where any path you take is going to hurt. But in that case, and that's most of us, right? When that happens, I'm going to take the path that's going to hurt, but going to get me to where I want to be. Yeah. So you've got to get back on a budget. Yeah. Hardcore. Beans and rice, rice and beans.
有时你会发现自己处于十字路口，无论走哪条路都会痛苦。但在那种情况下，我们大多数人都是这样，对吧？当这种情况发生时，我会选择那条虽然痛苦，但能带我到达我想去的地方的路。是的。所以你必须回到预算中。是的。彻底地。粗茶淡饭。
And no more rationalization of pulling out the credit card or I had to have a car that's $150,000. I don't give a crap. You don't go in debt again. Period. Period. Because then you end up strapped again back here. So nothing you have today can. can't be cleared up. The $20,000 car can be cleared up. The $3,000 credit card can be cleared up.
不要再为刷信用卡找借口，或者说我必须拥有一辆 15 万美元的车。我不在乎。你不能再负债了。句号。句号。因为那样你又会陷入困境。所以你今天拥有的任何东西都可以清理掉。2 万美元的车贷可以清理掉。3000 美元的信用卡债务可以清理掉。
And you can get back on the road. But you're going to have to get above the chaos and make these monkeys all dance because you're in the middle of a circus. And so you're going to, you're, you know, there's just monkeys run around everywhere and you're going to have to teach them how to get in the line and how to dance. And that's called a budget and you crack the whip on the money monster and make it behave. Money is a fabulous slave. It's a horrible master. And it's mastering you right now. It's adding to this anxiety of being overwhelmed. You feel overwhelmed with money, with your child, with your mom. And so this is an area you actually can control. The line that I was trained with that was really helpful for me when I entered into chaotic
你可以回到正轨。但你必须超越混乱，让这些猴子都跳起舞来，因为你正处于马戏团的中心。到处都是猴子在跑，你必须教它们如何排队，如何跳舞。这叫预算，你要挥舞鞭子让金钱怪兽表现得规矩点。金钱是一个极好的奴隶，却是一个可怕的主人。它现在正在掌控你。它增加了你被压垮的焦虑感。你对金钱、孩子和母亲感到不知所措。所以这是一个你实际上可以控制的领域。我受训时学到的那句话对我很有帮助，当我进入混乱
situations or facts or your friends, when everything feels like it's dumping on your head, what are the facts here? How much am I spinning on nursing? How much am I spinning on food? How much am I spinning on this car? And what can I do to get out of this mess following the facts path here? are big, and that's right for them to be big. The path out here is, what's the next right move? Hey guys, George Camel here. There are a lot of things you probably shouldn't ignore.
的情况时，事实是你的朋友，当一切都感觉压在你头上时，这里的事实是什么？我在护理上花了多少钱？我在食物上花了多少钱？我在车上花了多少钱？我能做些什么来遵循事实路径摆脱这个烂摊子？它们很大，它们确实很大。摆脱这里的路径是，下一步正确的行动是什么？嘿大家，我是 George Camel。有很多事情你可能不应该忽视。
Your check engine light, that weird smell in your fridge, the smoke detector that's been beeping for six days, and maybe most importantly, your phone bill. The things we ignore have a funny way of costing us the most, and your phone carrier is counting on you ignoring that overpriced bill month after month so they can keep
你的发动机检查灯，冰箱里那股奇怪的味道，已经响了六天的烟雾探测器，也许最重要的是，你的电话账单。我们忽视的事情往往会让我们付出最大的代价，而你的电话运营商正指望你月复一月地忽视那份价格过高的账单，这样他们就可以继续
charging you more and more. But that's not the case with Boost Mobile. You don't need keep overpaying when you can pay just 25 bucks a month for Boost Mobile's Unlimited plan. And the best part is you can bring your phone, keep your number, and pay just 25 bucks a month forever. That price will not go up. It is inflation proof. There's no contracts. There's no hidden fees. There's no catch. And since most smartphones have an e-sim these days, you can switch from the comfort of your home just like I did. So it's okay to notice when you're paying more than you should, but you shouldn't keep doing that. Stop overpaying for your phone service. Go to boostmobile.com slash Ramsey
向你收取越来越多的费用。但 Boost Mobile 的情况并非如此。当你只需每月支付 25 美元购买 Boost Mobile 的无限套餐时，你就不需要继续多付钱了。最棒的是，你可以自带手机，保留号码，并且永远只需每月支付 25 美元。这个价格不会上涨。它是抗通胀的。没有合同。没有隐藏费用。没有陷阱。而且由于大多数智能手机现在都有 eSIM，你可以像我一样在舒适的家中进行切换。所以，当你发现自己支付的费用超过应付金额时，意识到这一点是好事，但你不应该继续这样做。停止为你的电话服务多付钱。前往 boostmobile.com/Ramsey
and make the switch today. That's boostmobile.com slash Ramsey. $25 forever requires customers to remain active on Boost Mobile Unlimited Plan. Danny's in Columbus, Ohio. Hey, Danny, what's up? Hi there. Nice to talk to you again.
并立即切换。那是 boostmobile.com/Ramsey。“25 美元永久有效”要求客户保持在 Boost Mobile 无限套餐上。Danny 在俄亥俄州的哥伦布。嘿，Danny，你好吗？你好。很高兴再次和你交谈。
So my question was, I'm in Baby Step number two. I am actually recently engaged, and I'm super excited about that. And we're going on a wedding for May of 2027, and I was wondering how you would help or how you would balance trying to pay off debts and finance a wedding as well as a honeymoon without going into further debt. Good, good. That's a good. That's a good first goal.
所以我的问题是，我处于“小步计划”第二步。我最近订婚了，对此我超级兴奋。我们计划在 2027 年 5 月举行婚礼，我想知道你会如何建议，或者你如何平衡偿还债务和资助婚礼以及蜜月，而不陷入进一步的债务。好，好。这是一个很好的第一个目标。
Congratulations. So, um, thank you. What do you make and what does she make? Yeah, so I am a full-time pastor and a part-time lifeguard and I make roughly about $45,000 a year. What does she mean? She is a, yeah, so she's a welder. She's new in her career. She's currently making about $18 an hour, and she's looking to join the union. And if she's able to do that, she'll be able to make roughly $25 to $30 at hour starting out. Okay.
恭喜。那么，谢谢。你的收入是多少，她的收入是多少？是的，我是一名全职牧师和兼职救生员，我每年的收入大约是 4.5 万美元。她呢？她是一名焊工。她刚入行。她目前每小时赚 18 美元，她正在寻求加入工会。如果她能做到这一点，她起薪大约能达到每小时 25 到 30 美元。好的。
And has she just started the welding career? Because that's very low. Yeah, so she just graduated from trade school, and she currently worked. in full time for a local organization. Yeah. Well, she's being dramatically underpaid. Oh. Like half of what she should be paid in welding right now.
她刚开始焊接职业生涯吗？因为这太低了。是的，她刚从技校毕业，目前在一家当地机构全职工作。嗯。好吧，她的薪水被严重低估了。哦。就像她现在焊接工作应得薪水的一半。
There's a shortage of welders that have gone, that know how to actually, you know, lay a bead down. And so I don't know who got her this job, but they screwed her over. So, I mean, she can make this at Target stacking boxes without any education. I just paid some welders to do some work in my house, brother, and it was way, way more than what she's getting paid. Way, like, I'm smiling now. I can't believe that. Yeah. So anyway, that's thing one.
现在缺乏知道如何真正进行焊接的焊工。所以我不知道是谁给她找的这份工作，但他们坑了她。所以，我的意思是，她在 Target 堆箱子也能赚到这个数，而且不需要任何教育。我刚付钱给一些焊工在我家做了一些工作，兄弟，那比她现在的工资高得多。高得多，我现在都在笑。我不敢相信。是的。总之，这是第一件事。
Now, how much debt do you have? Well, I've been on baby step number two for a couple of years. I have no consumer debt right now. The only thing I have is federal student loans. That's consumer debt. I was an idiot. How much does your student loan debt? I was an idiot.
现在，你有多少债务？嗯，我进行“小步计划”第二步已经几年了。我现在没有消费债务。我唯一有的是联邦学生贷款。那是消费债务。我真是个白痴。你的学生贷款债务是多少？我真是个白痴。
And I took out a lot, and I currently got it down to about $90,000. Okay. And how much debt does she have? Absolutely zero. She's been a follower of the days of Ramsey plan. Excellent. She was 16. Okay.
我借了很多，目前我把它降到了大约 9 万美元。好的。她有多少债务？绝对为零。她一直是 Ramsey 计划的追随者。太棒了。她 16 岁时就是了。好的。
All right. And so what are you two planning to spend on the wedding? What's your budget that you came up with is you're going to spend on the wedding? Well, we wanted it to keep it small. And so we're looking at somewhere between $3,000 to $4,000 for the wedding. and then we wanted to take a two-week vacation to somewhere either in Texas or maybe not going to island or something. And so we're looking at probably about $2,000 to $3,000 to do that. Okay, so you need $6,000 by May?
好的。那么你们两个计划在婚礼上花多少钱？你们制定的婚礼预算是多少？嗯，我们想保持小规模。所以我们预计婚礼花费在 3000 到 4000 美元之间。然后我们想去德克萨斯州或某个岛屿度两周假。所以我们预计大约需要 2000 到 3000 美元。好的，所以你们到 5 月需要 6000 美元？
Give or take, yes, sir. Okay. That's $500 a month for a year. So $600 bucks a month in your monthly budget. Our $300 in your budget, $300 in her budget, goes into the wedding account. And then you work on your debt? Yes, sir. Unfortunately, that would be almost everything I'm chunking at my debt right now.
差不多吧，是的。好的。那一年每月 500 美元。所以你们每月预算中 600 美元。你们预算中 300 美元，她预算中 300 美元，存入婚礼账户。然后你们继续偿还债务？是的，先生。不幸的是，那几乎是我现在偿还债务的所有钱了。
Okay. So you need a better extra job. Your extra job doesn't do well. Or, and I don't want to give a controversial statement here, but you might not be able to do this ministry job at $45,000 because of previous decisions you made in your life to go six figures into student loan debt. A lot of ministers, as a matter of fact, somewhere around 80% of pastors today are by vocational, meaning they have a full-time job in addition to being a preacher. Yes, sir, and I do work full-time as a pastor, and, you know, I work about 20, 25 hours as a lifeguard and some instructor from my local YMCA.
好的。所以你需要一份更好的额外工作。你的额外工作做得不好。或者，我不想在这里发表有争议的声明，但你可能无法从事这份年薪 4.5 万美元的牧师工作，因为你之前在生活中做出的决定，导致你背负了六位数的学生贷款债务。事实上，很多牧师，大约 80% 的现代牧师都是双职位的，意味着除了当传教士外，他们还有一份全职工作。是的，先生，我确实全职担任牧师，而且，你知道，我还在当地的基督教青年会担任救生员和教练，每周工作大约 20 到 25 小时。
Yeah. I find both of those to be really impactful for our community. They're not impactful enough on the $90,000. Yeah, and you're going to burn yourself out. You're not going to be there for your community in five years because you're going to be completely cooked. Yeah. You need to go make some money so that you can remain in the work of the Lord. Because, you know, your lifeguard thing is semi-volunteer.
是的。我觉得这两者对我们的社区都非常有影响力。但它们在 9 万美元的债务面前影响力不够。是的，而且你会把自己累垮的。五年后你将无法为你的社区服务，因为你会被彻底烧干。是的。你需要去赚些钱，这样你才能继续从事主的工作。因为，你知道，你的救生员工作半志愿性质的。
I mean, you're not making any money there. And so you really, I mean, you do what you want to do, but you called us. And when you do that, you're always going to get our opinion because we're like an expert on our opinion. So, you know, I think you have an income problem. And you've got a slight outgo problem. only got 300 bucks a month out of 45,000. So you need to get on a detailed budget and you need be putting some money aside to the wedding. But you have a $6,000 goal by May and the two of you sit down and go, okay, maybe she's putting in four or you're putting in two. I don't care. But both of you
我的意思是，你在那里赚不到什么钱。所以你真的，我的意思是，你做你想做的事，但你打电话给了我们。当你这样做时，你总是会得到我们的意见，因为我们就像是意见方面的专家。所以，你知道，我认为你有收入问题。而且你有一点支出问题。每月只有 300 美元，年薪 4.5 万。所以你需要制定详细的预算，并且需要存一些钱用于婚礼。但你到 5 月有一个 6000 美元的目标，你们俩坐下来商量，好吧，也许她存 4000，你存 2000。我不在乎。但你们俩
have some career adjusting to do. Neither one of you are living up to your potential income producing right now. And income and money is not everything, but it does give you options. And you don't have any options. You're handcuffed. I am all about somebody deciding. You know what? I don't want to do this thing anymore. I want to go make a quarter of my quote unquote market value, whatever that is. And I want to just be here from my community. I love that idea. But if you've dug yourself a $90,000, $120,000 hole, you gave up that option, you gave up that option until you fill that hole back up. So the fastest way to fill that hole back up and get back even on even ground is to go work a whole bunch of jobs and even do jobs that you might not think
都有职业调整要做。你们俩现在都没有发挥出你们的潜在收入能力。收入和金钱不是一切，但它确实给了你选择。而你没有任何选择。你被戴上了手铐。我完全支持某人决定。你知道吗？我不想再做这件事了。我想去赚我所谓市场价值的四分之一，无论那是什么。我想只是为了我的社区在这里。我喜欢这个主意。但如果你给自己挖了一个 9 万、12 万美元的坑，你就放弃了那个选择，直到你把那个坑填满。所以填满那个坑并回到平地最快的方法就是去打很多份工，甚至做一些你可能认为
have impact, which I would argue with you in a different phone call, I think everybody who interacts to other people has an opportunity to impact people in a positive way, whether you're at fast food restaurant or a delivery person or whatever. But you gave up that right when you dug up those holes, I mean, when you dug yourself that big hole, you got to fill that sucker up. And that means you got to go get one job, two jobs. You may have to step away from your church for a season and go make a whole bunch of money doing something that you, quote, unquote, don't feel called to do. But I got to clean up this mess so that I'm here in the long haul to be here for my family, for my community for whatever I believe my faith is calling me to and all that kind of stuff.
没有影响力的工作，我会和你争论，在另一个电话里，我认为每个与他人互动的人都有机会以积极的方式影响他人，无论你是在快餐店还是送货员或其他什么。但当你挖那些坑时，你就放弃了那个权利，我的意思是，当你给自己挖了那么大的坑时，你必须把那个坑填满。这意味着你必须去找到一份工作，两份工作。你可能不得不暂时离开你的教会，去赚一大笔钱做一些你所谓“不觉得被召唤去做”的事情。但我必须清理这个烂摊子，这样我才能长久地在这里为我的家庭、为我的社区、为任何我相信我的信仰召唤我去做的事情服务。
Yep. That's exactly how it works. So again, we support pastors. We work with churches all across America and we have for 30 years. And so we've got a huge heart for people that want to serve in that way and in that role. But you don't, just because it's, you don't get a pass on the math. That's it. Yeah. You got, you have to address the math. And so in order to be able to stay in that kind of a role. And that's what we're looking for. Jessica's in Springfield, Missouri. Hi, Jessica.
是的。这正是它的运作方式。所以再次强调，我们支持牧师。我们与全美各地的教会合作，已经合作了 30 年。所以我们对那些想要以那种方式和角色服务的人怀有巨大的爱心。但你不能，仅仅因为它是，你不能在数学上获得豁免。就是这样。是的。你必须解决数学问题。为了能够留在那种角色中。这就是我们正在寻找的。Jessica 在密苏里州的斯普林菲尔德。嘿，Jessica。
How are you? Hi, basically. How are you doing? Better than I deserve. You're breaking up. Can you speak directly into your phone? Yes. Is this better?
你好吗？嘿，基本上。你怎么样？比我应得的要好。你的信号断断续续。你能直接对着手机说话吗？是的。这样好点吗？
Yes, ma'am. Much better, yeah. All right. My question is whether it's a debate between me and my husband. Yes. We'll solve it. We'll solve it. Fantastic.
是的，女士。好多了，是的。好的。我的问题是关于我和我丈夫之间的争论。是的。我们会解决它的。我们会解决它的。太棒了。
So the question is, whether or not he's being spoiled or if I'm being miserly. And it's related to cars. Okay. Both of you probably, but anyway, yeah. Both of us, probably. So we have three aging cars, and they're all doing fine right now, but we imagine that his commuter vehicle will be the first that needs to be replaced,
所以问题是，他是否被宠坏了，或者我是否太吝啬了。这与汽车有关。好的。你们俩可能都有，但无论如何，是的。我们俩可能都有。所以我们有三辆老旧的汽车，它们现在都运行良好，但我们想象他的通勤车将是第一辆需要更换的，
maybe in a year or so. The question is that he has bought several new cars in his lifetime, and that's what he would like to do again. And I disagree. I've never bought a new car, and I don't see any reason to. Okay. I suppose we are in Baby Step 7. We're free and clear.
可能在一年左右。问题是他一生中买过几辆新车，他想再次这样做。但我不同意。我从来没买过新车，我看不出有什么理由。好的。我想你们处于“小步计划”第七步。你们没有债务，清清楚楚。
What's your net worth? Probably about five and a half thousand. We're not millionaires. Five and a half thousand? I'm sorry, 500,000. 500,000. You're a half a millionaire. Okay.
你们的净资产是多少？大概 55 万左右。我们不是百万富翁。55 万？抱歉，50 万。50 万。你们是半个百万富翁。好的。
Half a millionaire. Yeah. Okay. We have the money to purchase a new vehicle, brand new, if we wanted to. I just don't really see the reason. So he says that after COVID happened, that depreciation on cars isn't what it used to be. He's wrong. Like comically wrong.
半个百万富翁。是的。好的。我们有钱购买新车，全新的，如果我们想的话。我只是真的看不出理由。所以他说 COVID 发生后，汽车的折旧不像以前那样了。他错了。简直是滑稽地错了。
Mathematically, arithmetic says he's wrong. Okay. And you can study it for 35 seconds on Google, and you'll figure this out. I mean, it doesn't take it, you know. jump around and look look at a new car that was issued a 23 model and see what the MSRP on it was manufacturer suggested retail price and then see what that 23 is selling for today and it is not up it's down and it's down dramatically and sorry but the fouchy pandemic didn't help with that and so i would agree yeah you win and i we tell people not to buy brand new cars because they go down so fast in
数学上，算术说他错了。好的。你可以在谷歌上研究 35 秒，你就会明白这一点。我的意思是，这不需要，你知道。四处看看，看看一辆 23 款的新车，看看它的建议零售价是多少，然后看看那辆 23 款的车今天卖多少钱，它没有上涨，它下跌了，而且下跌得很厉害。抱歉，福奇大流行并没有对此有所帮助，所以我同意，是的，你赢了。我们告诉人们不要买全新的车，因为它们在
value until you have at least a million dollars in net worth because they go down so fast in value and we don't we want you to build wealth not screw it up so you win you win and you win here's something that keeps a lot of parents up at night kids are growing up with more access to information than ever before in history but most of the content is calculated to keep them distracted make them mad and keep them scrolling not help them think for themselves world watch exists to be the to the algorithms. World Watch is a video news service built specifically for preteens and teens. They're daily 10-minute videos that explain what's happening in the world through a factual Christian worldview. No outrage, no noise, just clear reporting you can watch together and that your kids
价值上贬值太快，直到你的净资产至少达到一百万美元，因为它们贬值太快，我们不希望你破坏财富，而是希望你建立财富。所以你赢了，你赢了。这里有一些让许多父母彻夜难眠的事情。孩子们成长过程中接触到的信息比历史上任何时候都多，但大部分内容都是为了让他们分心、让他们生气、让他们不停地滚动屏幕，而不是帮助他们独立思考。World Watch 的存在就是为了对抗这些算法。World Watch 是一个专门为青春期前和青少年打造的视频新闻服务。他们每天 10 分钟的视频，通过事实性的基督教世界观解释世界上正在发生的事情。没有愤怒，没有噪音，只有你可以一起观看的清晰报道，而且你的孩子
can actually understand so they can come to the dinner table engaged and curious instead of worked up or zoned out. And I love that World Watch doesn't talk at kids. It gives family something to talk about. Because when my kids are older, I want them to be able to think for themselves and separate news from noise. And right now you can try Worldwatch free for 30 days. Click the link in the description or go to worldwatch.com news slash Ramsey and use promo code Ramsey to get started. The Ramsey offer includes your first full month free on top of the standard seven day trial. That's worldwatch.com news slash Ramsey. Here's what's weird. I went to a thing when I was 22 years old and the guy put up compound
实际上可以理解，这样他们就可以带着参与感和好奇心来到餐桌前，而不是情绪激动或心不在焉。我喜欢 World Watch 不会对孩子说教。它给家庭提供了谈论的话题。因为当我的孩子长大后，我希望他们能够独立思考，将新闻与噪音分开。现在你可以免费试用 World Watch 30 天。点击描述中的链接或前往 worldwatch.news/Ramsey 并使用促销代码 Ramsey 开始。Ramsey 的优惠包括在标准的七天试用期之外，再赠送第一个月的免费使用。那是 worldwatch.news/Ramsey。奇怪的是，我 22 岁时参加了一个活动，那个人把复利
interest on the table, on the board, rather. And he showed us the way compound interest works, $100 a month. And I heard this, 44 years ago. Okay. $100 a month invested from age 25 to age 65, and a decent growth stock mutual fund at market rates of return is $1,176,000. See, I think you should not be allowed to get out of high school until you know that equation. because it would stop all the stupid socialism stuff. Because you went, all I need is $100 a month, and I can live with, be a millionaire, you know, from age 25 to age 65, age 22, age 22, age 20 to age 60. I don't care which 40 years you want to pick it out.
放在了桌子上，或者说是黑板上。他向我们展示了复利的运作方式，每月 100 美元。我 44 年前听到了这个。好的。从 25 岁到 65 岁每月投资 100 美元，在市场回报率下，投资于一个不错的成长型股票共同基金，结果是 117.6 万美元。看，我认为你不应该被允许从高中毕业，直到你知道那个等式。因为它会阻止所有愚蠢的社会主义东西。因为你会想，我只需要每月 100 美元，我就可以生活，成为百万富翁，你知道，从 25 岁到 65 岁，22 岁，22 岁，20 岁到 60 岁。我不在乎你想选哪 40 年。
You can wait a 40 and do it at 80 if you want, but I wouldn't recommend it. See, anyone can become a millionaire. It's not that complicated. George and I are doing an in-depth nerd dive. I don't know exactly what an M-depth nerve dive means, but look that one up. We've listened to you talk. We know what it means. We know what it means.
你可以等到 40 岁，在 80 岁时做，如果你想的话，但我不会推荐。看，任何人都可以成为百万富翁。这并不复杂。George 和我正在进行深入的“书呆子式钻研”。我不知道“深入钻研”到底是什么意思，但去查查那个词。我们听过你说话。我们知道它是什么意思。我们知道它是什么意思。
At investing essentials, this is the third time I've ever done this event. And it's our two-night virtual event next week. It's the only place I unpack my entire playbook on investing, why I do what I do, why I don't do, including exact formulas and details on how I pick real estate, how I decide whether I'm going to keep it or not. All new content. We're also going into some wealth planning, a little bit of estate planning, looking at that. God, in case you're having trouble sleeping, come watch this event. It will put you right out. Yeah.
在投资要点上，这是我第三次举办这个活动。这是我们下周为期两晚的虚拟活动。这是我唯一解开我整个投资剧本的地方，我为什么做我所做的事，我为什么不做，包括确切的公式和关于我如何挑选房地产的细节，我如何决定是否要保留它。全是新内容。我们还将深入探讨一些财富规划，一点遗产规划，看看那个。天哪，如果你失眠的话，来看这个活动。它会让你立刻睡着。是的。
Tuesday and Wednesday evening, join us from the comfort of your own recliner. I'm kidding. Tickets start at 199. Get yours at ramsysolutions.com slash events or click the link if you're listening on podcast or YouTube. There's, God, John, there's like 700,000 people have signed up for this thing. That's crazy. It's crazy. It's going to be like a lot of people sleeping. But yeah, now, we're going to go into the details. We're going to give it. I mean, we've taken the material we did last year. And sadly, we've added a bunch to it. So it's actually not going to be two nights of two hours. Brace yourself, it'll be longer than two hours because we're just not going to be able to cover everything we wrote. And we want to do it all. So we're going to do it. There we go. Hey, it's going to be a lot. If you want a lot, you can get it next to Tuesday and Wednesday. the investing essentials
周二和周三晚上，在舒适的躺椅上加入我们。开个玩笑。门票 199 美元起。在 ramseysolutions.com/events 获取你的门票，或者如果你在播客或 YouTube 上收听，点击链接。天哪，John，有大约 70 万人报名参加了这个活动。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。这会像很多人在睡觉一样。但是的，现在，我们要深入细节。我们要提供它。我的意思是，我们拿走了去年做的材料。遗憾的是，我们增加了很多内容。所以它实际上不会是两个晚上的两个小时。做好准备，它会比两个小时长，因为我们只是无法涵盖我们写的所有内容。我们想做完所有事情。所以我们要做了。就是这样。嘿，这会很多。如果你想要很多，你可以在下周二和周三得到它。投资要点
two-night virtual event with George and me super let me say this I think this is important for a big reason that we don't talk about here in the building I'm not embarrassed to say
与 George 和我一起的为期两晚的虚拟活动，超级，让我说这个，我认为这很重要，原因是我们在这里的大楼里没有谈论的，我不尴尬地说
this is just truth I knew you when I joined this team I knew you had this show and I know you had this message and I knew you've been consistent with your message and I don't know how a nice way to say this
这只是事实，我加入这个团队时认识你，我知道你有这个节目，我知道你有这个信息，我知道你一直坚持你的信息，我不知道怎么用一种好的方式说这个
I didn't know you were as smart as you are or maybe a better way to say that is I didn't realize the level of intentionality with which you made decisions and even in the last five or six years the way all of our interactions are chopped up and edited and put on clips and then people respond to clips or whatever
我不知道你像你表现得那么聪明，或者也许更好的说法是，我没有意识到你做出决定时的那种意图水平，即使在过去五六年里，我们所有的互动都被切碎、编辑并放在剪辑中，然后人们对剪辑做出反应或其他什么
I can imagine there is millions of people who see you and hear you say a few things and this is an opportunity for them to really understand why you do what you do, not only why you teach people, but it's why you do this in your own house. And that to me makes this thing a worth its weight and gold. Way, way underpriced, if you ask me. Well, thank you. That's very nice. It's funny, but it's nice. Cecilia's in Orlando. Hey, Cecilia, what's up? Hi, how's it going today? Better than we deserve. How can we help?
我可以想象有数百万人看到你并听到你说几件事，这是一个让他们真正理解你为什么做你所做的事情的机会，不仅是你为什么教导人们，而且是你为什么在自己的家里这样做。对我来说，这让这件事物有所值。如果你问我，价格太低了。嗯，谢谢。那非常好。这很有趣，但很好。Cecilia 在奥兰多。嘿，Cecilia，你好吗？你好，今天怎么样？比我们应得的要好。我们能帮什么忙？
Lovely. So I'm about to get married. Yay. Yay, and I just got myself out of debt. And I'm going to marry into a lot of debt. Good. My husband is his spendthrift. And so I'm trying to figure out, I know once we get married, I'm going to help him with getting out. We've already started the Ramsey program for him. Oh, wow. Good.
可爱。所以我快要结婚了。耶。耶，我刚刚摆脱了债务。我要嫁入很多债务。好。我丈夫是个挥霍者。所以我试图弄清楚，我知道一旦我们结婚，我会帮助他摆脱债务。我们已经为他开始了 Ramsey 计划。哦，哇。好。
Yeah, and it's going pretty good. But once we get him out of debt, he's going to keep spending cash only. But how do I go about saving money? and not putting it all towards his spendthrift ways. How old are you guys? 51 and 52. Very cool. Very cool.
是的，进展相当不错。但一旦我们让他摆脱债务，他会继续只用现金消费。但我该如何存钱？而不把钱都花在他的挥霍方式上？你们多大了？51 和 52。非常酷。非常酷。
Well, congratulations. I think you're going to have a great marriage. Oh, we will. We've been together a long time. Opposites attract in good marriages. Spenders attract savers, and that's a good thing, because spenders need a saver. That way they don't have to retire and eat dog food. Right?
嗯，恭喜。我认为你们会有一段很棒的婚姻。哦，我们会有的。我们在一起很长时间了。在好的婚姻中，异性相吸。挥霍者吸引储蓄者，这是一件好事，因为挥霍者需要一个储蓄者。这样他们就不必退休后吃狗粮。对吧？
True. And savers need a spender in their life, so they have a life. Very true. He's the fun guy. You're not. I'm not. I like my books. And he's there to help you have fun.
真的。储蓄者在生活中也需要一个挥霍者，这样他们才有生活。非常正确。他是那个有趣的人。你不是。我不是。我喜欢我的书。而他在那里帮助你获得乐趣。
So I'm the spender at my house, oddly enough, and even though I teach this stuff, my wife is the natural saver. And so her natural tendency, if there's any kind of a, if there's any kind of a, motion involved in it is to draw back and save. In my case, I'm an abundance guy. She's a scarcity gal. And so I always figure I can get more money. So I'm going to go do it. And so, but I, we need each other to create wisdom in the middle. And wisdom is that we ought, we need to spend money on having a good life that we both are in agreement on. That's wisdom. We need to save and invest to create a quality future for us and our kids and our dogs and our cats, that's wisdom. And we need to be generous. And we need to be doing all of these things together. So you're going to have to,
所以奇怪的是，我是我家里的挥霍者，尽管我教这些东西，但我妻子是天生的储蓄者。所以她的自然倾向，如果有任何，如果有任何情感参与其中，就是退缩和储蓄。就我而言，我是个富足的人。她是匮乏的人。所以我总是认为我可以得到更多的钱。所以我打算去做。所以，但是，我们需要彼此在中间创造智慧。智慧是，我们需要花钱去过一种我们双方都同意的好生活。那是智慧。我们需要储蓄和投资来为我们和我们的孩子、我们的狗和我们的猫创造一个高质量的未来，那是智慧。我们需要慷慨。我们需要一起做所有这些事情。所以你将不得不，
your job when you guys are sitting and looking at the budget is to allow some fun to be in the budget and also make sure your savings is in there. His job is to allow some savings to be in the budget and make sure that his fun is in the budget. Because, because, listen, Cecilia. And then when it's all written down, you just go do it and there's no guilt. Because if that's not the case, what you're telling me is a far more concerning thing. And that is you sat down with this man that's about to be your husband and you've said, I'm uncomfortable with how you recklessly spend money. And he looked at his future wife and said, I don't care what you think.
当你们坐下来看预算时，你的工作是允许预算中有一些乐趣，并确保你的储蓄也在里面。他的工作是允许预算中有一些储蓄，并确保他的乐趣在预算中。因为，因为，听着，Cecilia。然后当一切都写下来时，你就去做，没有内疚。因为如果不是这样，你告诉我的事情就更令人担忧了。那就是你和这个即将成为你丈夫的男人坐下来，你说，我对你鲁莽花钱的方式感到不舒服。他看着他未来的妻子说，我不在乎你怎么想。
I don't care what you feel. I'm going to do what I want to do. And he didn't say that. He said, okay, let's get on a plan. Is that fair? No, we're on the plan. We have weekly budget meetings now. he just literally handed it all over.
我不在乎你的感受。我要做我想做的事。他没那么说。他说，好吧，让我们制定一个计划。公平吗？不，我们在计划中。我们现在有每周的预算会议。他只是把一切都交出来了。
No, no, no, no, no, no. You are not his mother. You're his wife. No, but we, right, and we do have our budget meetings, and he does have input, and I adjust accordingly, but right now we're paying off his debt. Good. Awesome. So there's not a lot of wiggle.
不，不，不，不，不，不。你不是他的母亲。你是他的妻子。不，但是我们，对，我们确实有预算会议，他确实有投入，我相应地调整，但现在我们正在偿还他的债务。好。太棒了。所以没有多少回旋余地。
Great. You don't need to wiggle. You need to pay off the debt. I completely agree. But I don't want him emotionally turn this over. The two of you, like two 51-year-old grown-ups are making grown-up decisions. together because it's good for our future. He's saying, I agree with Cecilia, I need to clean this up.
很好。你不需要回旋余地。你需要偿还债务。我完全同意。但我不想让他情绪化地把这个交出来。你们两个，像两个 51 岁的成年人，正在一起做出成年人的决定，因为这对我们的未来有好处。他说，我同意 Cecilia，我需要清理这个。
And so the two of us are going to work on that together. That's an adult decision. Mommy, take my bills and pay them for me is not what we want in a husband. Oh, no, no, that we don't play that game. And Cecilia, if y'all have been together for a while and he sat down and said, I want to marry you, and I'm going to change the way I'm doing things, I'm going to take this Dave Ramsey course. I'm going to follow these babysit things.
所以我们两个要一起努力。这是一个成年人的决定。“妈妈，拿走我的账单帮我付了”不是我们想要的丈夫。哦，不，不，我们不玩那个游戏。Cecilia，如果你们在一起有一段时间了，他坐下来对你说，我想娶你，我要改变我做事的方式。我要参加这个 Dave Ramsey 课程。我要遵循这些小步计划。
I'm going to do a weekly budget meeting. He loves you. But you showing up every meeting and going, well, he's just going to go spend it. Like, generally speaking, a husband will rise to their wife's level of belief in them. You know what I'm saying? Fair, yes. And if he's putting the work in, however clumsy and awkward it is, he's never done this in half a century, you seeing him do the next right thing, however uncomfortable it is or whatever, and you believing
我要进行每周预算会议。他爱你。但你每次会议都出现并说，嗯，他只是会去花掉它。就像，总的来说，丈夫会提升到妻子对他们的信任水平。你知道我在说什么吗？公平，是的。如果他投入了工作，无论多么笨拙和尴尬，他半个世纪以来从未这样做过，你看到他做下一个正确的决定，无论多么不舒服或其他什么，而你相信
in him, man, that goes a long, long way. So I'll just fast forward. I mean, 28 years old, almost 40 years ago, we lost everything because of my stupidity, borrowing too much money and flipping houses, and the bank called our notes, and we lost everything, went bankrupt. So, but that's not the same Dave today that's on the microphone. And Sharon will tell you, thank God I'm not still married to the same guy I married originally. Yes.
他，伙计，那会走很长很长的路。所以我快进一下。我的意思是，28 岁，将近 40 年前，因为我的愚蠢，借了太多钱和炒房，我们失去了一切，银行收回了我们的票据，我们失去了一切，破产了。但那不是今天在麦克风前的 Dave。Sharon 会告诉你，感谢上帝，我没有继续和最初结婚的那个男人在一起。是的。
He has grown. And so while my tendency is to spend, the spending that we do at the Ramsey House is very much within the wisdom guidelines. And even if it might make her a little bit uncomfortable sometimes and it makes me happy, but still, it's nowhere near where it was. It's intentional. I can still have my tendency, but do it with maturity. There you go. Most people think making a will is some huge legal project they'll get around to someday. If you're working hard to get out of debt and build wealth to change your family tree,
他成长了。所以虽然我的倾向是消费，但我们在 Ramsey 家所做的消费很大程度上是在智慧准则之内的。即使它有时可能会让她有点不舒服，它让我快乐，但仍然，它远没有以前那么严重。这是有意的。我仍然可以有我的倾向，但要成熟地去做。就是这样。大多数人认为立遗嘱是一个巨大的法律项目，他们总有一天会处理。如果你正在努力摆脱债务并建立财富来改变你的家谱，
don't miss one of the most important steps that can help protect it all. Making a will. At Ramsey, we trust and recommend Mama Bear legal forms. Mama Bear has taken something people assume is complicated and made it simple. Their wills are specific to. your state and they're built by attorneys to help you protect your family the right way. You're not downloading some generic form from the internet and hoping it will work. You'll have guidance every step of the way so you can be confident you're doing it right.
不要错过可以帮助保护这一切的最重要步骤之一。立遗嘱。在 Ramsey，我们信任并推荐 Mama Bear 法律表格。Mama Bear 已经把人们认为复杂的事情变得简单了。他们的遗嘱是针对你所在州的，并且由律师构建，以帮助你以正确的方式保护你的家庭。你不是从互联网上下载一些通用的表格并希望它能起作用。你将在每一步都得到指导，这样你就可以确信你做得对。
Plus, the whole process only takes about 20 minutes and August is National Make-A-Will month. Right now, you can go to Mama Bearlegalforms.com and save 25% on your will with the promo code Ramsey. It's their biggest discount of the year. But it ends August 31st. So don't wait. That's mama bearlegalforms.com for 25% off with the promo code Ramsey. Luke is in Fort Wayne, Indiana.
此外，整个过程只需约20分钟，而且八月是全国立遗嘱月。现在，您可以访问 MamaBearlegalforms.com，使用优惠码 Ramsey 即可享受 25% 的遗嘱服务折扣。这是他们全年最大的折扣，但将于 8 月 31 日结束。所以别再犹豫了。访问 mama bearlegalforms.com 并使用优惠码 Ramsey 即可享受 25% 的折扣。卢克来自印第安纳州韦恩堡。
Hey, Luke, what's up? Hello, what's up? How can we help? I was just wondering, my soon-to-be wife is starting college, or she just started college and she has enough for first semester's tuition and I was just wondering if after that we should take out student loans to cover it until she gets her job after school or if we should just pay it off and just live pretty tight for the next three years. How old are you guys?
嘿，卢克，你好吗？你好，有什么事吗？我们能帮你什么？我只是想问一下，我即将结婚的妻子刚开始上大学，她手里的钱只够付第一学期的学费。我在想，之后我们是应该申请学生贷款来支付学费，直到她毕业找到工作，还是应该直接付清学费，在接下来的三年里过得紧巴巴的。你们多大了？
I just turned 20. She just turned 18. And what's she studying in college? medical imaging so she wants to be a rad tech so she'll be making pretty good money coming out so a two-year program and she'll be making 50 uh no it's a four-year program i think really for medical imaging yeah yeah she well she was doing like extra stuff like there's more classes she can take to make more starting off maybe um she's 18 where did we get this information about this career?
我刚满 20 岁。她刚满 18 岁。她大学学什么专业？医学影像，她想成为一名放射技师，所以毕业后收入应该不错。这是一个两年制的课程，她毕业后就能挣 50……哦，不，我想医学影像应该是四年制的课程。真的吗？是的，她还在做一些额外的事情，比如她可以多修一些课程，这样起薪可能会更高。嗯，她才 18 岁，你们是从哪里得到关于这个职业的信息的？
Her second cousin does it for a living. Okay. You know how scary that sounds when you say it? Yeah, when you just said that, I puckered up pretty good, Luke. Okay, I want you and her to go to the hospital and talk to the hospital administrator
她表亲的表亲就是干这个的。好吧。你知道当你这么说的时候听起来有多可怕吗？是的，当你刚才那么说的时候，卢克，我紧张得皱起了眉头。好吧，我希望你和她去医院和医院管理人员谈谈，
and find out what they're paying and does it require a four-year degree. That's the first thing, okay, Because if we're going to study the purpose of studying, the primary purpose of studying, especially when we're broke people, is to create an opportunity in the marketplace that we can make more money. Otherwise, you could just go take a job at Target, right? Right. And so if we're going to make $18 an hour after going for four years, then we don't need to go get that degree. That's a dumb degree.
了解一下他们的薪资水平，以及是否需要四年制学位。这是第一件事，好吗？因为如果我们去学习，学习的主要目的，特别是当我们这些穷人去学习时，是为了在市场上创造一个能让我们赚更多钱的机会。否则，你大可以去塔吉特百货找份工作，对吧？没错。所以，如果我们读了四年书之后只能挣每小时 18 美元，那我们就不需要去拿那个学位了。那是个愚蠢的学位。
Okay. or if you get a degree in left-handed puppetry or some kind of bull crap degree, you know, you're going to end up being a barista. So, you know, so you need to really study what this is before you invest four years of your time and life into it, much less four years of money. And so that's thing one. Thing two is I think you're fairly new to this whole Ramsey thing and someone told you to call here some friend or relative and they tricked you. because we're really kind of known, Luke, for telling people to never take out a student loan for anything. Right. And you asked that question with great honesty, and it tells me that you probably have not listened to this show a lot.
好吧。或者如果你拿了一个左撇子木偶戏学位或者其他什么废话学位，你知道，你最终只能去当咖啡师。所以，你知道，在你投入四年的时间和生命，更不用说四年的金钱之前，你真的需要好好研究一下这是什么。这是第一点。第二点是，我觉得你对拉姆齐这一套还比较陌生，可能是某个朋友或亲戚让你打进来的，他们把你给骗了。因为卢克，我们其实是以告诉人们永远不要为任何事情申请学生贷款而闻名的。没错。你刚才问那个问题时非常诚恳，这告诉我你可能没怎么听过这个节目。
I'm pretty new listener. Yeah. It was just, like, currently I don't have the money, but I'd be able to save up. No, you ask me if you should borrow a student loan. That tells me that you don't know much about what we do. because 100% of the time we yell at people for taking out of student loan, okay? No. Under no circumstances do you take out a student loan?
我是个新听众。是的。只是，目前我没有钱，但我可以存钱。不，你问我是否应该申请学生贷款。这说明你对我们所做的事情了解不多。因为我们 100% 的时间都在斥责那些申请学生贷款的人，好吗？不。在任何情况下你都不应该申请学生贷款。
Yes, you investigate what is required for her to go into this field of study if she really wants this career or if she just thought it was a way to make money because her cousin said to, which scares the crap out of me. But yeah, I really want her to pick out what she wants to be in life and then what education does it take to do that. So we do not borrow money on student loans. The statistics are horrendous. 100% of the people that take out a student loan have a student loan. Only 57% of the people that start college finish. Okay.
是的，你要调查清楚如果她真的想要这个职业，或者她只是因为她表亲说这行赚钱才觉得这是个赚钱的方法，那么进入这个研究领域需要什么条件，这真的让我感到非常害怕。但是的，我真的希望她能选择她自己想成为什么样的人，然后看看需要什么样的教育才能做到这一点。所以我们不借学生贷款。统计数据太可怕了。100% 申请学生贷款的人都有学生贷款。只有 57% 开始上大学的人能毕业。好吧。
That's not even half. That's how bad colleges are. I agree. I decided to skip college and go straight into the workforce because I've been believing. Yeah. Well, and Luke, what we don't want to have happen for, we don't want you to be in the situation where two years into this four-year degree um you all have racked up 30,000 dollars in student loans and then she comes home with what
那甚至不到一半。大学就是这么糟糕。我同意。我决定放弃大学直接进入职场，因为我一直坚信这一点。是的。嗯，卢克，我们不希望发生的是，在四年制学位的两年后，你们背负了 3 万美元的学生贷款，然后她带着本该是
should be the greatest news of your life. I'm pregnant and now she's got to she's going to decide to stop going to school or she can't do this imaging program because she's pregnant and so she's got to do something else that student loan payment is still due and so that's what happens in real life. Yeah. So I was 18. I was 19. I was 20. I was 21. Dude, we had crazy roommates. I lived in some of the wildest living situations. I still took out student loans like a goofball. But, like, yes, y'all are scratching and clawing.
你一生中最好的消息回家了。我怀孕了，现在她必须决定停止上学，或者因为怀孕而无法完成这个影像课程，所以她必须做点别的，而那笔学生贷款还是要还的，这就是现实生活中发生的事情。是的。所以我 18 岁的时候，19 岁，20 岁，21 岁。伙计，我们有疯狂的室友。我住过一些最狂野的居住环境。我还是像个傻瓜一样申请了学生贷款。但是，是的，你们现在是在挣扎求生。
Y'all are eating, I mean, y'all are eating bologna sandwiches and rice and beans. Yes, y'all are just going to scratch and claw. And by the way, y'all could end up with a pretty amazing marriage together, figuring out ways to solve these problems without borrowing money because y'all are in this thing together. Yeah. So that's, it could be a cool thing three or four years down the road. Let's verify that this is the proper path. to get where you want to go. Let's verify that it is where we want to go.
你们在吃，我是说，你们在吃博洛尼亚香肠三明治和米饭豆子。是的，你们只是要挣扎求生。顺便说一句，你们最终可能会拥有一段非常美满的婚姻，一起想办法解决这些问题，而不需要借钱，因为你们是在一起面对这一切。是的。所以，这在三四年后可能是一件很酷的事情。让我们核实一下这是否是通往你想要去的地方的正确道路。让我们核实一下这是否是我们想要去的地方。
And then let's figure out the least expensive way to do it and pay cash for it. Those are the three things we would tell you to do coming out of this. I'm also going to send her a copy of Ken Collins' book, Finding the Work You're Wired to Do, because I wanted to spend some time thinking about who she is because we want to decide if we stay on this track or not. So, John, a thousand years ago, when I was a kid, there was a
然后让我们找出最省钱的方法并用现金支付。这就是我们建议你从这里走出来的三件事。我还要送她一本肯·科林斯的书《找到你天生适合的工作》，因为我想让她花点时间思考一下她自己是谁，因为我们要决定是否继续走这条路。所以，约翰，一千年前，当我还是个孩子的时候，有一个
the grandfather of the maybe the great grandfather of the motivational speaking movement was a guy named Earl Nightingale and Earl famously says and with this deep baritone voice Americans spend more time picking out a suit of clothes
励志演讲运动的祖父，也许是曾祖父，是一个叫厄尔·南丁格尔的人，厄尔曾有名言，他用那深沉的男中音说，美国人花在挑选一套衣服上的时间
than they do their career how'd you get that job my buddy went over there and got it my cousin did it that's not how you pick your career Okay. You look in the mirror and say, what did God design here? How am I designed?
比他们花在职业规划上的时间还要多。你是怎么得到那份工作的？我哥们过去找的，我表亲干的。那不是你选择职业的方式。好吧。你看着镜子说，上帝在这里设计了什么？我是如何被设计的？
What is it I'm supposed to do? And then with my natural giftings and talents, what kind of sharpening can I do called education and tools added in my belt called education to help me do what it is that I'm put together when I was knit in my mother's womb, according to Isaiah, what was I put? When God was knitting me together with a DNA-R-N-A double helix and a knitting needle, what was he making and what am I supposed to do? You need to think about that more than you think about the purse you pick out or the suit you pick out.
我应该做什么？然后用我天生的天赋和才华，我能做些什么样的磨练，也就是教育，以及我腰带里增加的工具，也就是教育，来帮助我做我被创造出来要做的事情，就像以赛亚书里说的，我在母亲腹中被编织时，我被放在哪里？当上帝用 DNA-R-N-A 双螺旋和编织针把我编织在一起时，他在制造什么，我应该做什么？你需要思考这个问题，比你思考你挑选的钱包或西装要多得多。
No way buys a suit anymore, but the hat you buy, whatever it is, the stuff we spend time on, a fret over what I'm going to buy with this stupid thing, and then we just go take a job because your cousin had it. And that might not be the case with her, but when he said that, it just went down my spine. Yeah. Or you're asking even bigger question that I always press on college students, especially college graduates.
现在没人买西装了，但你买的帽子，无论是什么，我们花时间在上面的东西，为我要买这个愚蠢的东西而烦恼，然后我们只是因为你表亲有那份工作就去做了。她可能不是这种情况，但当他说那话时，我脊背发凉。是的。或者你问的是我总是向大学生，特别是大学毕业生强调的更大的问题。
What kind of life do you want to have? Yeah. And does this job, instead of I want to build a life around this job, is this job in service to the person you want to become, like the life you want to hold? And if you want to help people in this particular job, man, you can do a lot of good for a lot of folks in a lot of different ways. But, man,
你想过什么样的生活？是的。这份工作，而不是我想围绕这份工作建立生活，这份工作是否服务于你想成为的那个人，比如你想拥有的生活？如果你想在这份特定的工作中帮助别人，伙计，你可以在很多方面为很多人做很多好事。但是，伙计，
sometimes you find yourself, I have to get a job because I got to go make money right now. Yeah. Or my dad was a doctor. My grandpa was a doctor. So I got to be a doctor. You know what you are? A miserable doctor. Man, I sat with a lot of those students sobbing.
有时你会发现自己，我必须找份工作，因为我现在必须去赚钱。是的。或者我爸爸是医生。我爷爷是医生。所以我必须成为一名医生。你知道你是什么吗？一个痛苦的医生。伙计，我和很多那样的学生坐在一起哭泣。
Miserable. I don't want to be here. Yeah. You know, I don't. Listen, if you're my dentist and you're a dentist because your mommy wanted you to be a dentist, I don't want to be your patient. No. Yeah. I think that's going to hurt.
痛苦。我不想待在这里。是的。你知道，我不想。听着，如果你是我的牙医，而你当牙医是因为你妈妈想让你当牙医，我不想成为你的病人。不。是的。我觉得那会很痛苦。
You know, I mean, think about it, guys. You suck at stuff that you do for other people rather than the way you were designed. Right. And so, you know, what is it that you've got natural giftings in? And let's lean into that and let's polish it and let's hone the craft to fit, you know, by adding education to the mix. I believe in education. But randomly, I'm going to be a lawyer because lawyers make money. Not all of them.
你知道，我的意思是，想想看，伙计们。你做那些为别人做的事情时表现得很糟糕，而不是按照你被设计的方式去做。没错。所以，你知道，你有什么天赋？让我们倾向于这一点，让我们磨练它，让我们通过在组合中增加教育来磨练手艺。我相信教育。但随机地，我要成为一名律师，因为律师赚钱。并非所有人都是这样。
some of them are really pretty broke. And I've, I spent several years studying attorneys who got everything they wanted and they were pretty miserable because they thought what they wanted was this number or this love, this name on their building or whatever. And what, what are you looking for in your life? What's,
有些人真的很穷。而且我，我花了好几年时间研究那些得到了他们想要的一切的律师，他们非常痛苦，因为他们认为他们想要的是这个数字，或者这种爱，这栋楼上的名字，或者其他什么。而你，你在生活中寻找什么？什么
what's going to be the score of your life, right? So that's a lot for, that's a lot more than just what, answering Luke's question, but it just kind of made me think about that, that deep baritone voice saying, Americans spend more time picking out a suit of clothes than they do. what their future career is going to be.
将是你人生的得分，对吧？所以这不仅仅是回答卢克的问题，但这让我想到那深沉的男中音说，美国人花在挑选一套衣服上的时间比他们花在未来职业规划上的时间还要多。
Well, and here's where Luke finds himself. Man, if y'all are young, was to say, 18 and 19 years old, getting married, what y'all need right now is some money. And if one of you knows, I want to go into the medical field. I want to do this thing. Like you said, go sit down with some people who do that job for a living and ask how that world works, not just get some salary advice from a second cousin. Yeah, here's what's weird.
嗯，这就是卢克现在的处境。伙计，如果你们很年轻，比如说 18 岁和 19 岁，要结婚了，你们现在需要的是钱。如果你们中有人知道，我想进入医疗领域。我想做这件事。就像你说的，去和一些以此为生的人坐下来谈谈，问问那个世界是如何运作的，而不是从表亲那里得到一些薪水建议。是的，奇怪的是。
They might hire you over there as an assistant to the assistant tech and pay your tuition. That's exactly right. Hey guys, it's Rachel Cruz. If you're working the baby steps, every major expense deserves a second look. And health care is one of the biggest expenses in most families' budgets. And that is why I recommend that you check out Christian healthcare ministries. CHM isn't insurance. It's a health-cost-sharing ministry. That means members help pay one another's medical bills. And they've been serving Christians since 1981. CHM programs start at just $115 a month. And here's why that matters. If you are paying more than you need to for health care, that money could be going toward paying off debt, building your emergency fund, or reaching your next financial goal. And your monthly cost isn't based on your medical history or where you live. Y'all, a lot of families find CHM gives them more room in the budget. That's why
他们可能会雇你做助理技师的助理，并支付你的学费。完全正确。嘿伙计们，我是瑞秋·克鲁兹。如果你正在执行“婴儿步骤”，每一项重大支出都值得重新审视。医疗保健是大多数家庭预算中最大的支出之一。这就是为什么我建议你看看基督教医疗部（CHM）。CHM 不是保险。它是一个医疗费用分担部。这意味着成员们互相帮助支付医疗账单。他们自 1981 年以来一直为基督徒服务。CHM 计划每月仅需 115 美元。这就是为什么这很重要。如果你在医疗保健上支付的费用超过了你的需要，那么这些钱就可以用来偿还债务、建立应急基金或实现你的下一个财务目标。而且你的月费不是基于你的病史或你住的地方。伙计们，很多家庭发现 CHM 给他们的预算留出了更多空间。这就是为什么
so many members say they're better with CHM. And right now, new members can reach receive a 50% credit towards their first month of membership. Go to CH Ministries.org slash budget and use promo code Ramsey. That's CHMinestries.org slash budget and promo code Ramsey. Welcome back to the Ramsey show in the Fair Winds Credit Union Studio. Anthony is in Canada. Hi, Anthony. How are you? Hey, Dave. How's it going?
这么多成员说他们有了 CHM 感觉更好。现在，新成员首次月费可获得 50% 的抵免。访问 CHMinistries.org/budget 并使用优惠码 Ramsey。那是 CHMinistries.org/budget 和优惠码 Ramsey。欢迎回到 Fair Winds Credit Union 工作室的拉姆齐秀。安东尼在加拿大。嗨，安东尼。你好吗？嘿，戴夫。怎么样？
Better than I deserve. What's up? I am just asking if I should stay at this one. job that I don't really like too much and the job and the pay is not that great or if I should go back to kind of what I was doing beforehand and I was making better pay but I have been working in that industry for like two years now and every so often I'd get into a job and they'd just be pretty much hiring for when they're slow and then they lay off like not even six months later. But I like that industry. What is the industry? Electrical. I was doing like electrical apprentice. Okay.
比我应得的要好。有什么事吗？我只是在问我是否应该留在这份我不太喜欢的工作上，而且工作和薪水也不是很好，或者我是否应该回到我以前做的事情，我以前赚的钱更多，但我已经在那个行业工作了大约两年了，每隔一段时间我就会进入一份工作，他们基本上只是在生意清淡时雇人，然后不到六个月就裁员。但我喜欢那个行业。是什么行业？电气。我以前做的是电气学徒。好吧。
Well, I mean, the electric, there's not a, I mean, that company might get slow, but the call for electricians does not ebb and flow that much. Yeah. It sounds like you've bought yourself into a corner, brother, either or? and I would love for you to consider 30 other options, 27 of which may be dumb, but just to free yourself from, it's not boring job, not making much money, but stable and risky job where I love the job and it pays well, but then they just might lay off at a moment's notice. Those are two not great options.
嗯，我的意思是，电气，没有一个，我的意思是，那家公司可能会变慢，但对电工的需求并没有那么大的起伏。是的。听起来你把自己逼进了死胡同，兄弟，要么这样要么那样？我非常希望你考虑其他 30 个选择，其中 27 个可能很愚蠢，但只是为了让自己从“无聊的工作，赚不到多少钱，但稳定”和“有风险的工作，我喜欢这份工作，薪水也不错，但他们可能会随时裁员”中解脱出来。这两个选择都不太好。
There's 300 other options, right? Yeah. So let's get a job that pays more and is stable and you like. Yeah, I've definitely tried. Yeah, I've definitely tried to. And just since I've been in that electrical industry for however long, it's primarily only electrical businesses that would hire me. This is why I took the other job, this job I'm currently doing, is to get something else on my resume. But, uh, okay, how old are you? I'm 21. I'm not that old yet. So when did you get all of these experience when you were 13? No, it's just been in the past like two, three years kind of thing.
还有 300 个其他选择，对吧？是的。所以让我们找一份薪水更高、稳定而且你喜欢的工作。是的，我肯定试过。是的，我肯定试过。而且自从我进入电气行业以来，基本上只有电气公司会雇佣我。这就是为什么我接受了另一份工作，我现在做的这份工作，是为了在我的简历上增加点别的东西。但是，嗯，好吧，你多大了？我 21 岁。我还不是那么老。所以你什么时候得到的这些经验，当你 13 岁的时候？不，这只是过去两三年左右的事情。
Yeah, sort of. Yeah, I've been to like maybe like five different electrical businesses, and they just have been pretty much all the same. Yeah, it wasn't that they saw someone with a limited resume. It's that they saw a 21-year-old. Yeah. And this is what, then he can do electricity, electrical work, and so we'll hire him to do electrical work. That's all it is.
是的，算是吧。是的，我去过大约五家不同的电气公司，他们基本上都一样。是的，并不是他们看到了一个简历有限的人。而是他们看到了一个 21 岁的人。是的。这就是，然后他可以做电工，电气工作，所以我们会雇他做电气工作。就是这样。
It's not, you're over-complicating this. And you're discounting the fact that you're being looked at as a youth. Yeah, yeah, for sure. And that changes the way they pocket this or bucket this when an employer is looking at you in this situation. So I think we would start fresh, and I'm going to send you a copy of Coleman's book, finding the work you're wired to do. And I want you to pretend like you had known. ever worked in your life and you were brand new.
这不是，你把这事复杂化了。而且你忽略了你被视为年轻人的事实。是的，是的，当然。当雇主在这种情况下看你时，这改变了他们把这放在口袋里或桶里的方式。所以我认为我们应该重新开始，我要送你一本科尔曼的书《找到你天生适合的工作》。我希望你假装你以前从未在生活中工作过，你是全新的。
And you just said, your dad just said, okay, you got to get out of the house. Go and be free my son. And you said, okay, what am I going to do with my life? What do you want to be when you grow up? Huh? What do you want to be when you grow up, Anthony? You know, so I want you to answer that question, kind of, and start fresh as if you didn't have all this other stuff weighing you down because it's probably going to take
你刚才说，你爸爸刚说，好吧，你得离开家了。去自由吧，我的儿子。你说，好吧，我这辈子要做什么？你长大后想成为什么样的人？嗯？你长大后想成为什么样的人，安东尼？你知道，所以我希望你回答那个问题，某种程度上，重新开始，就好像你没有所有这些其他压在你身上的东西一样，因为它可能会带
you to one of those other 300 options that John's talking about. And then you discover what Henry Cloud calls your desired future that might be completely different than anything we're talking about. As a matter of fact, I think it should be. And then you say, okay, what must be true for me to be one of those kinds of people making that kind of money? Oh, wait a minute. I'm going to have to take a two-year certification program. Oh, I'm going to have to go to trade school. Oh, I'm going to have to get a four-year degree.
你到约翰谈到的那 300 个其他选择中的一个。然后你发现亨利·克劳德所说的你渴望的未来，那可能与我们谈论的任何事情完全不同。事实上，我认为应该是。然后你说，好吧，为了成为那种赚那种钱的人，我必须具备什么条件？哦，等一下。我得参加一个两年制的认证课程。哦，我得去职业学校。哦，我得拿一个四年制学位。
Oh, I got to go to graduate work. I don't know. Whatever it is to be one of those, then go do those things to be one of those. And at 21, your chief focus is becoming the most excellent electrician possible. And there's going to be some grinding out that happens here. Like Dave said, it stinks. It's a bummer or whatever. But, man, go become the best freaking electrician in your part of, in your province there.
哦，我得去读研究生。我不知道。无论成为那种人需要什么，然后去做那些事情成为那种人。在 21 岁时，你的主要重点是成为最优秀的电工。这里会有一些磨练。就像戴夫说的，这很糟糕。这很扫兴什么的。但是，伙计，去成为你所在省份最棒的电工吧。
And you will be hired. Like, the people will want you on their squad. Exactly. Show up early, leave late, work while you're there. Take weekend jobs. I have a family. Take a bath. smile and they'll never get rid of you.
你会被雇用的。人们会想要你在他们的团队中。完全正确。早到，晚走，在工作时努力工作。接周末的工作。我有家庭。洗个澡。微笑，他们永远不会解雇你。
I mean, it's so simple. And take Saturday and Sunday jobs at people's homes, changing plugs out and changing light fixtures out and putting in ceiling fans, like become excellent at the craft. Yeah. And the adjacent crafts, man. And dude, I'm telling you, as a guy that's spent a lot of money on electricians recently, bro, the demand is there. You got like firsthand knowledge of welders, electricians.
我的意思是，这太简单了。在人们家里接周六和周日的工作，更换插头、更换灯具、安装吊扇，变得精通这门手艺。是的。还有相邻的手艺，伙计。伙计，我告诉你，作为一个最近在电工身上花了很多钱的人，兄弟，需求就在那里。你有焊接工、电工的第一手知识。
You're a real wealth of knowledge today. Your son-in-law is helping me on with some home projects. but man, the work they're doing is second to none, and they are very proud of it. Yeah, they're as they should be. They like it. So hang on, we'll pick up and send you a copy of that book. I'm finding the work you're wired to do. Oh, good one, Dave.
你今天真是知识渊博。你的女婿正在帮我做一些家庭项目，但伙计，他们做的工作是首屈一指的，他们对此感到非常自豪。是的，他们理应如此。他们喜欢它。所以等着，我们会去拿并送你一本那本书。我正在寻找你天生适合的工作。哦，好书，戴夫。
Bo-to-boom. It is the title. Sullivan is in Las Vegas. Hey, Sullivan, what's up? How good one? Better than I deserve. How can I help? So I'm kind of in a pickle a little bit.
砰。这就是标题。沙利文在拉斯维加斯。嘿，沙利文，有什么事吗？好书？比我应得的要好。我能帮你什么？所以我有点陷入困境了。
So my rent went from like 1750 up to like 1950. Your wife are debating whether to stay here, move out. We're trying to pay off debt as much as you can. We have like $20,000 or $20,000 in debt. So we're kind of just looking around, see if it's better for us to stay or to move into something like cheaper. So that's kind of what we're at right now. Cool. Was it just the two of you?
所以我的房租从 1750 涨到了 1950 左右。你妻子在争论是留在这里还是搬出去。我们正试图尽可能多地偿还债务。我们有大约 20,000 美元或 20,000 美元的债务。所以我们只是在四处看看，看看留下来还是搬到更便宜的地方对我们更好。所以这就是我们现在的处境。酷。只有你们两个人吗？
It's me, my wife, and my two daughters and my sister-in-law. Oh, not just the two of you. Yeah. So you've got to have a place that has a lot of bedrooms, huh? Yeah, so we're looking for like a three-bedroom, but Vegas can be pretty expensive. And what's the sister-in-law? How does this play into this? Well, she lived in California, and so she came out to Vegas to stay, to live with us, to go to college.
是我，我妻子，我的两个女儿和小姨子。哦，不仅仅是你们两个。是的。所以你必须有一个有很多卧室的地方，对吧？是的，所以我们正在寻找像三居室这样的房子，但拉斯维加斯可能相当昂贵。小姨子是怎么回事？这在其中起什么作用？嗯，她住在加利福尼亚，所以她来到拉斯维加斯住，和我们住在一起，去上大学。
And so my wife and her are both going to CSN out here in Las Vegas. Now is she paying rent? No, we're just trying to help her. She's 19, so she was in a box. That's nice. You're broke. Okay. Yeah. Are you in a position to help her?
所以我的妻子和她都在拉斯维加斯的 CSN 上学。现在她付房租吗？不，我们只是想帮助她。她 19 岁，所以她被困住了。那很好。你没钱。好吧。是的。你有能力帮助她吗？
No. He's broke. Because you're getting ready to go rent a house you wouldn't have rented because you have a sister-in-law tagging along. Yeah. If it's just you and the two kids, you might do something completely different. So that enters into this equation. So, Sullivan, rent is patience. Patience while you get out of debt and save up money to buy a house.
不。他没钱。因为你正准备去租一栋你本来不会租的房子，因为你有一个小姨子跟着。是的。如果只有你和两个孩子，你可能会做完全不同的事情。所以这进入了这个等式。所以，沙利文，房租是耐心。在你还清债务并存钱买房时的耐心。
The less you pay for your patience, the faster you get out of debt and save up money to buy a house. And so I'm going to take the cheapest possible. rent I can because it's for a period of time. It's not my way of doing life. It's living like no one else so that later I can buy a house. Living like no one else so later I can live like no one else and give like no one else. So you get out of debt, save your emergency funds, save your down payment because you have a low rent and then you talk about buying a house. And as you do that, your credit will clean up because you don't have any debt. And you'll be more and more eligible for that while you're cleaning all this mess up. but you're going to have to lean in hard on all that and you don't look at renting as a way of life then we look at as a temporary stop we're camping here till we get our more permanent home
你为耐心支付的越少，你还清债务和存钱买房的速度就越快。所以我将采取尽可能便宜的房租，因为它是一段时间。这不是我做生活的方式。这是像其他人一样生活，以便以后我可以买房子。像其他人一样生活，以便以后我可以像其他人一样生活并像其他人一样给予。所以你还清债务，存下你的应急基金，存下你的首付，因为你有低房租，然后你谈论买房子。当你这样做时，你的信用会清理干净，因为你没有任何债务。当你清理所有这些烂摊子时，你会越来越有资格这样做，但你必须努力投入所有这些，你不要把租房看作一种生活方式，我们把它看作一个临时的停靠站，我们在这里露营，直到我们得到我们更永久的家
that we actually own and Sharon and I often called it camping although there was no literal camping involved we're going to camp here for a little while as a way of telling our brain this is temporary just just for a season notifying my body it's not going to be here long it's going to be somewhere else I'm just camping
我们真正拥有的，莎伦和我经常称之为露营，尽管没有字面上的露营，我们要在这里露营一会儿，作为告诉我们大脑这只是暂时的，只是为了一个季节，通知我的身体它不会在这里待太久，它会去别的地方，我只是在露营
We're going to camp out here a while. Running a business is hard enough. The tools you use to run it should make your job easier. Too many business owners spend more time fighting their software than selling their products. You didn't sign up to become a web developer. You signed up to build a business you're proud of. And Shopify gets that. With Shopify, you can design and launch a professional storefront fast without the headaches.
我们要在这里露营一会儿。经营企业已经够难了。你用来经营它的工具应该让你的工作更轻松。太多的企业主花更多的时间在与软件斗争，而不是销售他们的产品。你没有注册成为一名网页开发人员。你注册是为了建立一个你引以为豪的企业。Shopify 明白了这一点。使用 Shopify，你可以快速设计和启动专业的店面，而不会头疼。
Everything you need to start selling is built in. And when your customers are ready to buy, Shopify's Purple Shop Pay button is one of the best converting checkouts in the world, which means fewer abandoned carts and more sales. And when questions come up because they always do, Sidekick, Shopify's built-in AI assistant, is there to help you keep moving. All you need is the idea. Shopify handles the rest. Start your free trial at Shopify.com
你需要开始销售的一切都内置在里面。当你的客户准备购买时，Shopify 的紫色 Shop Pay 按钮是世界上转换率最高的结账方式之一，这意味着更少的放弃购物车和更多的销售。当问题出现时，因为它们总是会出现，Sidekick，Shopify 的内置 AI 助手，就在那里帮助你继续前进。你只需要想法。Shopify 处理其余的事情。在 Shopify.com 开始你的免费试用
slash Ramsey. That's Shopify.com slash Ramsey. Shopify.com slash Ramsey. Marcus is in Minneapolis. Hey, Marcus, how are you? I'm good. How are you? Better than I deserve.
/Ramsey。那是 Shopify.com/Ramsey。Shopify.com/Ramsey。马库斯在明尼阿波利斯。嘿，马库斯，你好吗？我很好。你呢？比我应得的要好。
What's up? Thanks for having me on. So my fiance and I are getting married here in about three weeks, and we are looking to build a home on 5-8. that my dad gifted to us. Um, so for reference, we make about 150,000 gross per year. We have 110,000 in savings right now. Um, our only debt is 25,000 in student loans.
有什么事吗？谢谢你让我上节目。所以我的未婚妻和我大约三周后要在这里结婚，我们正在寻求在 5-8 英亩的土地上建一个家，那是我爸爸送给我们的。嗯，作为参考，我们每年总收入约为 150,000 美元。我们现在有 110,000 美元的储蓄。嗯，我们唯一的债务是 25,000 美元的学生贷款。
Um, but the house we want to build is around 400 to $450,000. But following the 25% rule, it probably looks like we'd only be able to afford something around a $300,000 range. So we're just looking for some guidance. Well, you've already got that. We told you $300,000, didn't we? Yeah, yeah. How old are you guys?
嗯，但我们想建的房子大约是 400 到 450,000 美元。但遵循 25% 的规则，看起来我们可能只能负担得起 300,000 美元左右的东西。所以我们只是在寻求一些指导。嗯，你已经有了。我们告诉过你 300,000 美元，不是吗？是的，是的。你们多大了？
We're both 28. If you put today, if you take 25 of that $150,000 you have and pay off your student loans, and then you put $100,000 down on a $400,000 house, that brings you to $300,000, doesn't it? Yes, but I'm saying, like, I think I'd have to get the loan amount down closer to, like, $200,000 for that to work. And you'll make a combined $150,000? Yes.
我们都 28 岁。如果你今天投入，如果你拿出那 150,000 美元中的 25% 来还清你的学生贷款，然后你在 400,000 美元的房子上支付 100,000 美元，这会让你达到 300,000 美元，不是吗？是的，但我说的是，我觉得我必须把贷款金额降到 200,000 美元左右才能行得通。你们合计赚 150,000 美元？是的。
Gross, yeah. Okay. Well, I mean, there's a concept that, I mean, you can do whatever you want to do, your grownups and you're allowed to do that, but you're calling and asking our advice and the guidelines that we have that we show people how not to be house poor so that they can, you know, have margin in their budget to invest and to be generous and to buy the next car for cash and to pay cash at Christmas and not have the house own them. And so, I mean, what if you told me that the house you wanted was $700,000, but you can afford $200,000? You know, you would just say, you would use the words that no one uses in America. We can't afford it.
总收入，是的。好吧。嗯，我的意思是，有一个概念，我的意思是，你可以做任何你想做的事，你们是成年人，你们被允许这样做，但你打电话询问我们的建议，以及我们向人们展示如何不成为房奴的指导方针，这样他们就可以，你知道，在他们的预算中有余地去投资，去慷慨，去用现金买下一辆车，在圣诞节用现金支付，而不是让房子拥有他们。所以，我的意思是，如果你告诉我你想要的房子是 700,000 美元，但你只能负担得起 200,000 美元？你知道，你只会说，你会使用美国没人使用的词。我们负担不起。
And so you've got to decide what you can afford. Now, there's a couple of other options. I mean, no one says that in the first year of marriage that you should build a home. As a matter of fact, I would probably tell you, having built several homes, that's not good for your marriage to build a home in the first year of marriage. This is the opportunity to fight like you have never fought in your life. And so, you know, and it's a brand new tender relationship, marriage. And, you know, it's a, you know, building a home is a lot.
所以你必须决定你能负担得起什么。现在，还有几个其他选择。我的意思是，没人说在结婚的第一年你应该建一个家。事实上，我可能会告诉你，在建了几栋房子后，在结婚的第一年建一个家对你的婚姻不好。这是战斗的机会，就像你一生中从未战斗过一样。所以，你知道，这是一个全新的、脆弱的关系，婚姻。而且，你知道，这是一个，你知道，建一个家有很多。
It's a lot of details, a lot of decisions, and a lot of compromises between the two of you of what color something's going to be or what the thing is going to be. And, I mean, sometimes one of the spouses just says they're not going to be involved. and the other one does it, but that's not healthy either. You both are going to live there. You both should speak into what the house is, okay, and you both should have a vote, and then by the time you do that, it's going to be strenuous, relationally. I wouldn't tell people not to build a house in the first year of marriage relationally. So having said all of that and given that little speech,
有很多细节，很多决定，以及你们两人之间关于某种东西是什么颜色或东西会是什么的很多妥协。而且，我的意思是，有时其中一个配偶只是说他们不会参与，而另一个做了，但这也不健康。你们俩都要住在那里。你们俩都应该对房子是什么发表意见，好吗，你们俩都应该有一票，然后当你这样做的时候，它在关系上会很吃力。我不会告诉人们不要在结婚的第一年建房子。所以说了所有这些，并发表了那个小演讲，
might be okay to just go run an apartment on the other side of town. Is this land adjacent to your family? Yeah, we have a family farm. we're just kind of getting a chunk of that. Be good for your wife to not be next door to her mother-in-law in the first year of marriage. Yeah, I get that. Marcus, what's your take-home every month?
可能只是去城另一边租个公寓也可以。这块地和你的家人相邻吗？是的，我们有一个家庭农场。我们只是要得到其中的一部分。你妻子在结婚的第一年不和她的婆婆住隔壁对她有好处。是的，我明白了。马库斯，你每个月的到手收入是多少？
It kind of varies because my work's a little seasonal, but I pick up some part-time work in the wintertime. So I don't know. It probably varies between 8 to 10, depending. I make more in the summer. Okay. And is your wife work? Your fiancé, getting ready to be. And that 150 is the total of the two of you? Yes. And the total take home pay from the two of you would be about what? Not 100% sure, to be honest.
它有点变化，因为我的工作有点季节性，但我会在冬天做一些兼职工作。所以我不知道。它可能在 8 到 10 之间变化，取决于。我在夏天赚得更多。好吧。你妻子工作吗？你的未婚妻，准备成为。那 150 是你们两个的总和？是的。你们两个的总到手工资大约是多少？老实说，我不确定。
Okay. Well, that would be a number you would need to have the discussion we're having. Yeah, because I feel like you're underselling a bit. I feel like you've, like to get that 25% mark, I think you're close. I just did some napkin math here on the computer. I think you're closer than you think. Yeah. But I also agree. But it's also okay to wait a year. I also agree with Dave, relationally. Tell your dad, like, man, thank you for this five acres. We want to spend one year just figuring it out ourselves.
好吧。嗯，那将是你需要进行我们正在进行的讨论的数字。是的，因为我觉得你有点低估了。我觉得你，为了达到那个 25% 的标记，我觉得你很接近。我刚才在电脑上做了一些餐巾纸数学。我觉得你比你想象的要近。是的。但我同意。但等一年也没关系。我也同意戴夫的观点，在关系上。告诉你爸爸，像，伙计，谢谢你这五英亩土地。我们想花一年时间自己弄清楚。
A cabin in the woods. And we're going to save a little bit more money so we can put more down in the sense. No one near any of you people. Yeah, I'm serious, man. It'll be great for you. And then when you come over there, your marriage is more knit and more matured. And when you come over there next door to her mother-in-law, then she can handle it a little better. and I know your mother's great, but she doesn't know that yet.
树林里的小木屋。我们要多存一点钱，这样我们就可以多付一点。没人靠近你们任何人。是的，我是认真的，伙计。这对你来说会很棒。然后当你过来时，你的婚姻更紧密，更成熟。当你过来到她婆婆隔壁时，她就能更好地处理它。我知道你妈妈很棒，但她还不知道。
So it may take a while. And you're going to have family members that say, oh, you're going to throw away money and we're giving you... They don't get a vote. Yeah, it's a good season to learn, like, who gets to speak into what you do next. That's awesome. I'm taking a year off if I'm you. Yeah. Pay off the student loan today, stack cash for a year, rent a cheap apartment.
所以可能需要一段时间。而且会有家庭成员说，哦，你要浪费钱，我们给你……他们没有投票权。是的，这是一个学习的好季节，比如，谁有权对你接下来要做的事情发表意见。那太棒了。如果我是你，我会休一年假。是的。今天还清学生贷款，存一年的现金，租一个便宜的公寓。
You'll build a different house, by the way, too. 100%. You'll know each other better. after a year and you'll build a better house together. Spend a year tour in houses to see what you like. You like this kitchen. You like that bathroom. Yeah.
顺便说一句，你也会建一栋不同的房子。100%。一年后你们会更了解彼此，你们会一起建一栋更好的房子。花一年时间参观房子，看看你喜欢什么。你喜欢这个厨房。你喜欢那个浴室。是的。
Clip, you know, build a Pinterest board with all the ideas you like and all that kind of stuff and take pieces of a house. And, you know, the last house we built, it was three different houses that we found pieces of and we bolted them together with an architect and made it look right. Well, and even Sharon explaining parts of the house and the way this new house, you all built like it was a learned experience from another house and exactly but it was like we built a different house because of that other we had lived together in another in another situation so yeah yeah you'll build a different home um that you'll be more happy with yeah you'll do you'll do it
剪辑，你知道，用你喜欢的所有想法和所有那种东西建立一个 Pinterest 板，并拿走房子的碎片。而且，你知道，我们建的最后一栋房子，是我们找到碎片的三个不同的房子，我们用建筑师把它们连接在一起，让它看起来正确。嗯，甚至莎伦解释房子的部分，以及这栋新房子的方式，你们所有人建它就像它是从另一栋房子学到的经验，完全正确，但就像我们建了一栋不同的房子，因为我们住在另一个，在另一个情况下，所以是的，是的，你会建一个不同的家，嗯，你会更快乐，是的，你会做的
you'll be some yeah wait a year wait a year and pay off student loan that's my advice oh the trick is will you do it now that's where it comes down i know we're against polymarket but we should have a polymarket like would they one of those oh we're against betting a gambling site but if there was a are they going to do it or not that'd be fun yeah we could just take
你会是某种，是的，等一年，等一年，还清学生贷款，这是我的建议，哦，诀窍是你现在会做吗，这就是归结为，我知道我们反对 Polymarket，但我们应该有一个 Polymarket，就像他们会，那些哦，我们反对投注一个赌博网站，但如果有一个他们会做还是不做，那会很有趣，是的，我们可以只是采取
like an informal poll with no money on it there we go-you okay yeah we don't have to do go fund me with it will they do it or will they not will they do it thumbs up thumbs down John in Madison Wisconsin hey John how are you
像一个非正式的民意调查，没有钱在上面，我们去，你还好，是的，我们不必用它做 GoFundMe，他们会做还是不会做，他们会做，竖起大拇指，竖起大拇指，约翰在威斯康星州麦迪逊，嘿约翰，你好吗
hi I'm good how are you doing better than I deserve how can I help So I have a question regarding starting a 401k. So I have about $50,000 in debt, 30,000 of those are student loans and about $20,000 on a car. And following the baby steps, I know I'm supposed to start paying down my debt, but at 30 years old, I'm kind of just getting a little bit of... God, you're so old. You're going to die broke.
嗨，我很好，你怎么样，比我应得的要好，我能帮你什么，所以我有一个关于开始 401k 的问题。所以我大约有 50,000 美元的债务，其中 30,000 美元是学生贷款，大约 20,000 美元是汽车贷款。遵循婴儿步骤，我知道我应该开始偿还债务，但在 30 岁时，我有点只是得到一点……上帝，你太老了。你会死得很穷。
You're going to die poor. You're so old. John, you're a thousand years old. That is kind of what my thought was. How are you getting around to Walker? Have you got a wheelchair? Yeah, you are so stinking young. Don't whine about being old.
你会死得很穷。你太老了。约翰，你一千岁了。这确实是我的想法。你是怎么绕过沃克的？你有轮椅吗？是的，你太年轻了。不要抱怨变老。
You're not panicking at 30 years old. You need to get your butt out of debt and follow the baby step. You're not old. You're not old. You're not old. Yeah, temporarily, but I want you to get after it, man. I mean, we won't keep us debt around for four years like it's a pet. It's just, what did you say?
你在 30 岁时没有恐慌。你需要把你的屁股从债务中解脱出来，遵循婴儿步骤。你不老。你不老。你不老。是的，暂时，但我希望你追求它，伙计。我的意思是，我们不会像宠物一样保留债务四年。这只是，你刚才说了什么？
It was, 50 grand? 50 grand. What do you make? Me and my last combined income is about 175 per year. So pay it off in a year. One year, dude. Okay. What's $5,000 a month in your budget?
是，5 万？5 万。你赚多少？我和我的最后合计收入大约是每年 175。所以一年内还清。一年，伙计。好吧。你的预算里每月 5,000 美元是什么？
Our margin is about $4,000 to $5,000 per month. Done. Well, cut something else out. I want to $6,000 then. Be done in 10 months. Okay. Just be done with it. And then this is not a question.
我们的利润大约是每月 4,000 到 5,000 美元。完成。嗯，切掉别的东西。我想要 6,000 美元。10 个月内完成。好吧。只是完成它。然后这不是一个问题。
You're a whole 31 years old when you start your 401k. But just trying to do six things at once is how people do nothing. And by the way, you'll have $5,000 a month to invest to do whatever you want to with. Once you get rid of this stupid debt. Changes your life, man. Attack it like it's a disease because it is. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Hey, it's Deloney.
当你开始你的 401k 时，你已经 31 岁了。但只是试图一次做六件事是人们什么都不做的方式。顺便说一句，你每月将有 5,000 美元可以投资，做任何你想做的事情。一旦你摆脱了这个愚蠢的债务。改变你的生活，伙计。像对待疾病一样攻击它，因为它就是。这个节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。嘿，我是 Deloney。
Listen, BetterHelp just released their annual state of stigma report. It's full of tons of data about why so many people avoid getting help for their mental and emotional health challenges. Here is one data point that really stood out to me. More than three out of four Americans reported anxiety or depression symptoms in the previous two weeks. If that's you and you're carrying stress, anxiety or depression or symptoms of these things, just talking to someone can help you more than you realize. I recommend BetterHelp. BetterHelp is an online therapy platform that matches you with one of their 30,000-plus licensed therapist based on your goals.
听着，BetterHelp 刚刚发布了他们的年度耻辱状况报告。它充满了大量关于为什么这么多人避免为他们的心理和情感健康挑战寻求帮助的数据。这里有一个数据点对我来说真的很突出。超过四分之三的美国人在过去两周内报告了焦虑或抑郁症状。如果你是这样，并且你带着压力、焦虑或抑郁或这些事情的症状，仅仅和某人交谈可以比你意识到的更多地帮助你。我推荐 BetterHelp。BetterHelp 是一个在线治疗平台，根据你的目标将你与他们的 30,000 多名持牌治疗师之一匹配。
and preferences. It's easy. It's super convenient and you can message your therapist in schedule sessions right in the platform. And if the first therapist you're matched with isn't the right fit, you can switch therapists at any time for no extra cost. Don't let stigma stand in the way of support. Visit betterhelp.com slash Ramsey and get 10% off. That's BetterHelp. HELP.com slash Ramsey. Our question of the day is brought to you by Y-R-R-Fi, missed private student loan payments can leave you feeling like your financial goals are on hold. Why Refi helps borrowers explore low fixed rate refinancing options that fit your budget so you can move forward with an actual plan.
以及偏好。这很简单。它非常方便，你可以在平台上直接给你的治疗师发消息并安排会话。如果和你匹配的第一位治疗师不合适，你可以随时更换，无需额外费用。不要让偏见阻碍你寻求支持。访问 betterhelp.com 斜杠 Ramsey，即可享受 10% 的折扣。那是 BetterHelp.com 斜杠 Ramsey。我们今天的提问由 Y-R-R-Fi 提供，错过的私人学生贷款还款会让你觉得财务目标停滞不前。Why Refi 帮助借款人探索适合你预算的低固定利率再融资方案，这样你就可以带着实际的计划继续前行。
Visit yrefi.com slash ramsay might not be in all states. Dave, I feel like this question is directly aimed at me. And so I just want to call out that it hurts already. This is a personal affront to John Deloney. to Deloni. Today's question comes from Diana in Washington, D.C. Since my husband and I have gotten married, we've justified certain purchases by saying, quote, it's an investment. For example, $2,000 worth of high-quality business suits that would last for many years. As we started listening to The Ramsey Show, we began to suspect that we aren't using the term it's an investment in the right way.
访问 yrefi.com 斜杠 ramsay，可能并非在所有州都适用。戴夫，我觉得这个问题是直接冲着我来的。所以我只想说，这已经让我感到受伤了。这对约翰·德洛尼来说是一种人身攻击。致德洛尼。今天的问题来自华盛顿特区的戴安娜。自从我和丈夫结婚以来，我们一直通过说“这是一种投资”来为某些消费辩护。例如，价值 2000 美元的高品质商务套装，可以穿很多年。当我们开始收听《拉姆齐秀》时，我们开始怀疑我们对“这是一种投资”这个词的使用方式是否正确。
Is it ever appropriate to refer to a purchase as a quote-unquote investment, even if we don't expect it to generate an income or profit? If not, how, should we be thinking about purchases like these to decide if they're right for us? It's never an investment. It's wise consumption. Ooh, good line. Or it's unwise consumption, one of the two. But I really think my guitars and my hunting gear and my gym, those are investments.
将购买行为称为所谓的“投资”是否合适，即使我们并不指望它能产生收入或利润？如果不是，我们应该如何思考这类购买，以决定它们是否适合我们？这绝不是投资。这是明智的消费。哦，说得好。或者是不明智的消费，二者必居其一。但我真的认为我的吉他、狩猎装备和健身房，那些都是投资。
Yeah, I mean, the thing is this, there's a couple things that when I first start teaching this stuff, people start throwing all these sayings at me. And they're all pretty good. Stuff like, you know, rich people ask how much, poor people ask how much down how much a month. Okay? Wise people buy an expensive item, rich people do, that will last 20 years. And poor people, unwise people, buy a cheap item that feels good right now and lasts 20 minutes. And so it's kind of like we're teaching the kid, they're buying a toy and you're going,
是的，我的意思是，事情是这样的，当我刚开始教这些东西时，人们开始向我抛出所有这些说法。它们都相当不错。比如，你知道，富人问“多少钱”，穷人问“首付多少，月供多少”。好吗？明智的人会购买昂贵的物品，富人会这样做，因为这能用 20 年。而穷人、不明智的人，会购买便宜的物品，虽然现在感觉不错，但 20 分钟就坏了。所以这有点像我们在教孩子，他们正在买一个玩具，而你会说，
that toy is going to break by the end of the week. Or you can buy this item, this toy, and it's going to last. It's built. It's a good, you know, it's a tonka truck, right? It's going to last generationally. I got tonka trucks at three generations now. So, you know, that kind of stuff. So, you know, what is a wise purchase?
那个玩具到周末就会坏掉。或者你可以买这个东西，这个玩具，它会很耐用。它是制造出来的。它很好，你知道，它是一辆 Tonka 卡车，对吧？它可以代代相传。我现在有三代人都在玩 Tonka 卡车。所以，你知道，就是那种东西。所以，你知道，什么是明智的购买？
And so, you know, you buy a quality thing. So an example would be I would suggest you buy a two-year-old high-quality automobile instead of a brand new Dodge Neon. Right. Which is going to be crap by Friday because it was. was crap when you bought it on Monday. And so, you know, I mean, but that's the difference in a wealthy mentality and a poor mentality. I'm going to, I just want something shiny and new, even if it's cheap in quality and won't last.
所以，你知道，你买的是高质量的东西。举个例子，我会建议你买一辆两年的高质量汽车，而不是一辆全新的道奇 Neon。对吧。那车到周五就会变成垃圾，因为它在周一买的时候就是垃圾。所以，你知道，我的意思是，这就是财富心态和贫穷心态的区别。我只是想要一些闪亮的新东西，即使它质量低劣且不耐用。
In her case, she's talking about that. That's what Diana's talking about is a quality, a quality suit. It's going to last you. It's a timeless cut and material. It's not a high fashion item. That's going to be a fat item. But that you can wear that. forever.
在她的案例中，她谈论的是那个。戴安娜谈论的是一种质量，一种高质量的套装。它会很耐用。它是永恒的剪裁和材质。它不是那种高档时尚单品。那会是一时的流行。但你可以穿它。永远。
I wear on media and oftentimes on stage, I'll wear a black blazer. Okay? And I don't own a tie anymore. I got out of that business. But I've got three or four of those that I paid a lot of money for and I think they're approaching 10 years old now. And they, you know, they're hanging in the closet here. They're hanging in the closet at the house and so on.
我在媒体上，经常在舞台上，我会穿一件黑色西装外套。好吗？而且我不再拥有领带了。我退出了那个行业。但我有三四件我花了很多钱买的西装，我想它们现在快 10 年了。它们，你知道，挂在衣柜里。它们挂在房子的衣柜里，诸如此类。
You know, backstage at the event center. So if I need one, I got the exact same cut, custom made, high quality item. You know, and so it travels well because it's not going to wad up. And, you know, it's a good, that's, but that's not an investment because I can't turn around and sell it at a profit. And that's the definition of an investment. Yes. It goes up in, the investment's going to pay you money out and or go up in value and you can resell it. And clothing definitely doesn't qualify.
你知道，在活动中心的后台。所以如果我需要一件，我有完全相同的剪裁、定制、高质量的单品。你知道，它很适合旅行，因为它不会起皱。而且，你知道，这是一个好的，那是，但这并不是投资，因为我不能转手以利润卖掉它。而这正是投资的定义。是的。它会升值，投资会给你带来金钱回报和/或升值，你可以转售它。而服装绝对不符合条件。
Just ask the people at the consignment sale. And so, yeah, that, that, but you can call it a wise consumption. and it's a good, it's an interesting question. And what I do love about her question is, is that words do matter. Yes. They give your brain signals. Because if you call it an investment rather than wise consumption, it gives you permission to double down.
去问问寄售店的人就知道了。所以，是的，那，那，但你可以称之为明智的消费。这是一个有趣的问题。我喜欢她问题的一点是，词汇确实很重要。是的。它们会给你的大脑发送信号。因为如果你称之为投资而不是明智的消费，它会给你加倍投入的许可。
Well, and that's where I get called out because I've used the phrase, oh, this is really an investment over and over my life. And it's just been a bad justification for I really want this thing and I want to get the nicest version of this thing. Yeah. And so if I call it an investment for whatever reason, it makes it okay. instead of having the courage to say, you know what, I just want this, and I've saved up for it, and me wanting this is enough. Yeah.
嗯，这就是我被指出的地方，因为我一生中一遍又一遍地使用“哦，这真的是一项投资”这个短语。这只是一个糟糕的借口，因为我真的很想要这个东西，而且我想买这个东西最好的版本。是的。所以如果我出于某种原因称它为投资，它就变得可以接受了。而不是有勇气说，你知道吗，我只是想要这个，我已经为它存了钱，我想要这个就足够了。是的。
And I don't need all this other baggage to it to justify for myself. Exactly. I want a nice thing. I think I quit using, one of the times I learned to not use this was I was 26 years old. I was making a lot of money in the real estate business. And before I went broke, and I bought a Jaguar, which I grew up in a neighborhood where they couldn't spell Jaguar. So, much less I even knew what one was. So it was very impressive to me that I had a jaguar.
而且我不需要所有这些额外的包袱来为自己辩护。完全正确。我想要一个好东西。我想我停止使用，我学会不使用这个词的时候是我 26 岁的时候。我在房地产行业赚了很多钱。在我破产之前，我买了一辆捷豹，我长大的那个社区里，他们连捷豹怎么拼都不知道。所以，更不用说我知道那是什么了。所以我拥有一辆捷豹让我印象非常深刻。
I thought it was, you know, B-A, right? So I roll up at my grandpa's house, and my grandpa Ramsey was a Scotsman. He was a classic grandpa. I mean, pull the crooked nails out of the board, straighten them out and put them in a coffee can. You know this grandpa, right? He never threw away anything. A child of the Great Depression, worked 38 years for Alcoa Aluminum, saved every dollar he ever had, never invested any of it, just saved it, and just stacked to cash. And he comes out, and he was a sweet man. He came out, and I'm there in my little
我以为它是，你知道，很棒，对吧？所以我开到我爷爷家，我的拉姆齐爷爷是个苏格兰人。他是一个典型的爷爷。我的意思是，把弯曲的钉子从木板里拔出来，拉直，放进咖啡罐里。你知道这个爷爷，对吧？他从不扔掉任何东西。大萧条时期的孩子，为美国铝业公司工作了 38 年，存下了他赚的每一美元，从不投资，只是存起来，把现金堆起来。他走出来，他是一个可爱的人。他走出来，我穿着我的小
double-breasted suit, and I think I'm a really cool 26-year-old. And he said, what is that? I said, it's a jaguar grandpa, grandpa. He said, wow, so fine-looking automobile. He said, what did that cost? And I think at the time it was like $35,000 or something, which today would be $150,000, right? And I said, $35,000. He goes, oh, my God, I've never spent that on a car. He said, that is a fine car. I said, well, grandpa, it's a great car. It's a great investment. And he said, really?
双排扣西装，我觉得自己是一个非常酷的 26 岁年轻人。他说，那是什么？我说，这是捷豹，爷爷，爷爷。他说，哇，看起来很不错的汽车。他说，那花了多少钱？我想当时大概是 35,000 美元左右，今天相当于 150,000 美元，对吧？我说，35,000 美元。他说，天哪，我从来没在车上花过那么多钱。他说，那是一辆好车。我说，好吧，爷爷，这是一辆好车。这是一项伟大的投资。他说，真的吗？
That's amazing. He said, so in 10 years, will that car be worth? And I said, and he said, well, honey, my investments go up. But that's the same thing, right? It's that same mentality. Now, that car, if I had paid cash for it and wasn't leveraged to my eyeballs, of getting ready to go broken real estate business trying to appear to be something I'm not,
太神奇了。他说，那么 10 年后，那辆车会值多少钱？我说，他说，好吧，亲爱的，我的投资会升值。但这不就是同一回事吗，对吧？这就是同样的心态。现在，那辆车，如果我付的是现金，而不是杠杆到眼球，准备在房地产行业破产，试图表现得像我不是的那样，
which is the case in that situation, totally shallow as I could be, right? I mean, classic, classic putting on the pose. But if I had paid cash for the car and I had the wealth, I still should not have used the phrase, it's an investment. It's consumption that I can afford. And then I want. So it's wise consumption and I like it. And that's an okay answer.
在这种情况下，我表现得非常肤浅，对吧？我的意思是，典型的，典型的装模作样。但如果我付的是现金，而且我有财富，我仍然不应该使用“这是一项投资”这个短语。这是我负担得起的消费。而且我想要。所以这是明智的消费，我喜欢它。这是一个可以接受的答案。
at least then I wasn't trying to defend it as if it was going up in value, which is what he called me on. But that's the thing. If it's not going up in value and you can't turn around and resell it or you don't propose it's going to go up in value, then you're not, it's not an investment. So we bought a boat and it's an investment in our family. No, it's consumption for your family. It's not an investment. Boats do not go up in value. None of them.
至少那时我没有试图为它辩护，好像它会升值一样，而这正是他指出的。但这就是重点。如果它不会升值，而且你不能转手卖掉，或者你不打算让它升值，那么你就不是，它就不是投资。所以我们买了一艘船，这是对我们家庭的投资。不，这是为你家庭的消费。这不是投资。船不会升值。一艘都不会。
Two best days of your life. The day you buy a boat, the day you sell it, right? That's the old saying. Now, I don't know that because I've never sold my boat. No, I've sold them, got a better one. But yeah. So I'm still a boat guy. I'm not against boats.
你生命中最美好的两天。买船的那天，卖船的那天，对吧？那是句老话。现在，我不知道，因为我从来没卖过我的船。不，我卖过，换了更好的。但是的。所以我仍然是个玩船的人。我不反对船。
But the point being, don't, well, we're investing in our children by taking them to Disney. No, you're consuming an experience. And your value is that you want to spend money on experiences rather than other things. Okay, that's fine. Just own it. Quit acting like it's something. it's not. Right. And that's what she's calling out wisely here. Yeah. I like that. That's a good discussion. Words matter. Out of the abundance of the heart, the mouth speaks. So, you know,
但重点是，不要说“我们带孩子去迪士尼是在投资我们的孩子”。不，你是在消费一种体验。你的价值观是你愿意把钱花在体验上，而不是其他事情上。好吧，那没问题。承认这一点就行了。别再装作它是别的什么东西了。它不是。对。而这正是她在这里明智地指出的。是的。我喜欢那个。那是一个很好的讨论。词汇很重要。心里充满什么，口里就说出来。所以，你知道，
make sure your heart's aligned on this. Okay, we're consuming this money. We can afford it. It's a wise consumption. It's a reasonable purchase given our situation. But we're not going to call it something it's not, which is an investment. Oh, that's so good. And I'll even say this. The baggage that I brought to it, man, it took me a while to unpack this. I'll probably unpack this the rest of my life, is that underlying I'm not worth that. Or guys like me don't play guitars like that. I haven't earned that. I'll never like that's people who buy that kind of thing.
确保你的心在这方面是一致的。好吧，我们正在消费这笔钱。我们负担得起。这是一次明智的消费。考虑到我们的情况，这是一个合理的购买。但我们不会把它称为它不是的东西，即投资。哦，那太好了。我甚至会说这个。我带来的包袱，伙计，我花了一段时间才解开这个。我可能会在余生中解开这个，那就是潜在地我觉得我不值得。或者像我这样的人不玩那样的吉他。我没有赚到那个。我永远不会像那样，那是买那种东西的人。
So you're acting like it's going to go up in value because that makes it okay because you're not worth doing it for you. That's it. And for me taking ownership of I want this. my wife and I have agreed on it and it's okay if I get it. It's okay. And it checks, it's a part of our life rhythm, right? That's good. I like that. But that's, that was for me getting over like,
所以你表现得好像它会升值，因为这让它变得可以接受，因为你不值得为你自己做这件事。就是这样。对我来说，承担起“我想要这个”的责任，我和我妻子已经达成了一致，如果我买了它也没关系。没关系。它检查了，它是我们生活节奏的一部分，对吧？那很好。我喜欢那个。但那是，那对我来说是克服像，
I'm not worth $2,000 suit. Like, I'm not that guy. I'll never be that guy. But if it's an investment, I can do that, right? Yeah. It keeps you from buying stuff to impress other people. That's that to me is the most important thing. Hey, I want to talk to you for a second about, love and not love like in Titanic or something, I mean responsible love, the kind of love that moves you to take care of the people closest to you. And one of the most important ways to show that kind of love is by having term life insurance. If you have anyone depending on you, a spouse,
我不值得穿 2000 美元的西装。就像，我不是那种人。我永远不会成为那种人。但如果这是一项投资，我就可以那样做，对吧？是的。它能防止你为了给别人留下深刻印象而买东西。对我来说，这是最重要的事情。嘿，我想和你谈谈关于爱，不是像《泰坦尼克号》那样的爱，我的意思是负责任的爱，那种促使你照顾身边最亲近的人的爱。而展示那种爱最重要的方式之一就是购买定期人寿保险。如果你有任何依赖你的人，配偶，
kids, anyone, you need term life insurance. Term life insurance gives your family real protection if the unthinkable happens so they can spend their time grieving and not worrying about how the bills are going to get paid. Zander is a broker who works for you, shopping the top companies to find the right coverage options for your needs and your budget. In many cases, there are options available with no medical exam and instant approval. My wife and I had term life insurance through Zander for years long before I worked at Ramsey because we trust them. Getting term life insurance is a way of saying, I love you when you can no longer say it yourself. Go to zander.com or call 1-800-356-4-282 to find the coverage that fits your family.
孩子，任何人，你都需要定期人寿保险。如果发生不可预想的事情，定期人寿保险能给你的家庭提供真正的保护，这样他们就可以花时间去悲伤，而不是担心账单如何支付。Zander 是一家为你工作的经纪人，他们会对比顶级公司，找到适合你需求和预算的正确保险方案。在许多情况下，有无需体检和即时批准的选项。我和我妻子在拉姆齐工作很久之前，就通过 Zander 购买了定期人寿保险，因为我们信任他们。购买定期人寿保险是一种当你无法再说出口时，说“我爱你”的方式。前往 zander.com 或致电 1-800-356-4-282 找到适合你家庭的保险。
One of the biggest things that is a mistake people make is thinking they can skip having a will because they're too young for a will or too healthy for a will or they don't own anything. Well, guess what? You don't get to pick when you die. So, sadly, sometimes that happens to young and healthy people. A will helps protect your family. It gives clear instructions, keeps your loved ones, from having to guess what you wanted. while they're going through a difficult time. If you're ready to create a will, go to mama bearlegal.com.
人们犯的最大错误之一是认为他们可以跳过立遗嘱，因为他们太年轻或太健康，或者他们什么都没有。好吧，猜猜怎么着？你无法选择什么时候死。所以，可悲的是，这种情况有时会发生在年轻健康的人身上。遗嘱有助于保护你的家庭。它提供明确的指示，让你的亲人在经历困难时期时，不必猜测你想要什么。如果你准备好立遗嘱，请前往 mama bearlegal.com。
If you're not sure where to start, text quiz to 33789, and we'll help you figure out which option, whether an attorney or mama bear is your best option. Jennifer is in Charlotte, North Carolina. Hi, Jennifer. How are you? Hey, I'm good. How are you guys? Better than we deserve. What's up? Well, I was wanting to know if I should go back to school.
如果你不确定从哪里开始，发送短信 quiz 到 33789，我们会帮你弄清楚哪个选项，无论是律师还是 Mama Bear，是你的最佳选择。詹妮弗在北卡罗来纳州夏洛特。你好，詹妮弗。你好吗？嘿，我很好。你们好吗？比我们应得的要好。怎么了？嗯，我想知道我是否应该重返学校。
Well, if I should go to school. I've never been to college and the job that I've been in, although I've risen through the ranks position-wise, I can't go any further without a four-year degree. What do you do? I work in the cafeteria. I'm a trainer for them. And so I've been a worker. I've been a system manager, a manager.
嗯，如果我应该去上学。我从来没上过大学，虽然我在工作中职位上有所提升，但没有四年制学位我就无法再进一步了。你是做什么的？我在自助餐厅工作。我是他们的培训师。所以我一直是个工人。我当过系统经理，经理。
What is it that you can't do because you don't have a four-year degree? Is it just corporate policy? It is. And, yeah, it is definitely required. I've tried every avenue I can think of. and I can't be in a supervisory role and or. How long have you worked there? I've worked there for almost 20 years.
因为没有四年制学位，你有什么做不了的？这只是公司政策吗？是的。而且，是的，这绝对是必需的。我尝试过我能想到的每一个途径。但我不能担任主管角色和/或。你在那里工作多久了？我在那里工作了快 20 年了。
Okay. And so if you get a four-year degree in what, nutrition or what? Honestly, it could probably be in anything. Probably anything. I'm thinking business. Just to check the corporate box. and then your income today is what? I'm 65.
好的。所以如果你获得四年制学位，学什么，营养学还是什么？老实说，可能什么都可以。可能什么都可以。我在考虑商业。只是为了勾选公司的框框。然后你今天的收入是多少？我 65 岁。
$65,000 a year is what you make? Yeah. How old are you? 50. Okay, and what would you make four years from now if you got a degree in any old thing? Well, a person of my work experience, other than college and caliber, they make around 75 to 85. doing the exact same job? Doing not what I do, but doing what I would want to be able to do.
一年 6.5 万美元是你赚的？是的。你多大了？50。好的，如果你在四年后获得任何旧学位的学位，你会赚多少钱？嗯，一个有我工作经验的人，除了大学和能力，他们赚大约 7.5 万到 8.5 万。做同样的工作？不是做我做的，而是做我想要能够做的工作。
Which is what? Be a supervisor or maybe a... Over the cafeteria. A training specialist. Well, it would be over several cafeterias, like 18. And my thought process is that even if it takes, me five or six years. If I, being 50, that would still give me an additional five, six years.
那是什么？当主管或者也许是……负责自助餐厅。培训专家。嗯，那会是负责几个自助餐厅，比如 18 个。我的想法是，即使它花，我五六年时间。如果我，50 岁，那仍然会给我额外的五、六年。
Okay. What I do like is the idea of improving yourself, putting some tools in your belt for you to be worth more and earn more. I like that. I don't like that you're doing it for an artificial ceiling that shouldn't be there. And so that makes me want to quit and go work for someone else. um instead um my husband said something similar yeah i mean because this is stupid that you have to have at a four-year degree in left-handed puppetry so you can go run 18
好的。我喜欢提升自己、为自己增加一些工具，让你变得更有价值、赚得更多的想法。我喜欢那个。我不喜欢你这样做是为了一个本不应该存在的虚假天花板。所以这让我想要辞职去为别人工作。嗯，而不是，嗯，我丈夫说了类似的话。是的，因为这很愚蠢，你必须拥有左手木偶戏的四年制学位，这样你才能去经营 18 个
cafeterias and you know how to run a cafeteria off the back of your hand without thinking about it and these morons in corporate america have decided that a four-year degree somehow makes you a genius somebody with a four-year degree came up with this policy that's how much of a genius they are so So I don't like that part of the discussion at all, but I love the idea of continuing personal growth. Continued personal growth is the best investment human beings can make. Going to events, going to seminars, reading books, studying, getting another certification, another degree, constant state of learning in a culture where the rate of change is so rapid that it's blinded, is necessary to win and to grow and to be better.
自助餐厅，而且你知道如何闭着眼睛经营自助餐厅，而这些美国企业界的白痴决定，四年制学位不知何故让你成了天才。一个拥有四年制学位的人想出了这个政策，这就是他们有多天才，所以我根本不喜欢讨论的那部分，但我喜欢继续个人成长的想法。持续的个人成长是人类能做的最好的投资。参加活动、参加研讨会、阅读书籍、学习、获得另一个认证、另一个学位，在变化率如此之快的文化中保持不断的学习状态，这是获胜、成长和变得更好的必要条件。
And so I like all of that. And so I would tell you to go to school and study something. I don't mind that a bit. I also think you probably need to look at working somewhere else. John, what are you thinking? Yeah, I'm thinking, one, at what a costly corporate mistake to not put somebody of your experience, caliber, leadership ability, into the next right position that will improve everything for the company, their bottom line, their employee retention, their insider knowledge, all of it, simply for
所以我喜欢所有这些。所以我建议你去上学，学习一些东西。我一点也不介意。我也认为你可能需要考虑在别处工作。约翰，你在想什么？是的，我在想，第一，不把像你这样有经验、有能力、有领导力的人放到下一个正确的职位上，这对公司来说是一个多么昂贵的企业错误，这会改善公司的一切，他们的底线、员工保留率、内部知识，所有这些，仅仅因为
this one box. It's just corporations deciding we're going to outsource, we're going to use a metric to outsource value, and we're going to use a metric called degree or not degree as... As a hard stop. I mean, you know, we have some policies around Ramsey that we say that we start. the policy with almost never. Okay, we almost never hire relatives of current team members. Because if you fire one, you lose the other one usually.
这一个框框。这只是企业决定我们要外包，我们要使用一个指标来外包价值，我们要使用一个叫做学位或没有学位的指标作为……作为硬性停止。我的意思是，你知道，我们在拉姆齐有一些政策，我们说我们开始。政策几乎从不。好的，我们几乎从不雇佣现有团队成员的亲属。因为如果你解雇了一个，通常就会失去另一个。
So we just almost never do it. But we have occasionally. When common sense super, when common sense superimposed and stepped on top of a policy, then we put the policy down. And I've worked in university settings, which are the epicenter of this, right? You've got to have a degree to breathe at a university campus, and I get it. I've had two different universities and two different employees that I would put as some of the best employees I've ever worked with had no degree, but they were so skilled and I gave them a path to eventually if they wanted to, but I went and fought on their behalf, right? And so I'm frustrated there.
所以我们几乎从不这样做。但我们偶尔也会。当常识超越并凌驾于政策之上时，我们就放下政策。我曾在大学环境工作过，那是这种现象的中心，对吧？在大学校园里，你必须有学位才能呼吸，我明白。我有两所不同的大学和两名不同的员工，我把他们列为我共事过的最好的员工，他们没有学位，但他们技术非常娴熟，我给了他们一条路径，如果他们想的话，但我去为他们争取了，对吧？所以我对此感到沮丧。
On the other side of it, I grew up in a home where what Dave said is really wise. So in what he said is very specific. my mom took her first community college class at the age of 41 and it was simply I want to get some training and some education so that I can go make some more money and she found a whole new world and so she graduated with her PhD at 63 and got tenured as, you know, at 57 got tenure as a professor at 63. That was not even on her radar, not even her planet. And here was this woman from Texas that spent in her mid-70s was teaching over at Oxford overseas. It gave her a whole new world, but the the pursuit, and Dave was right here, was she wanted to grow herself and she wanted to keep learning and keep getting better. It wasn't driven by an artificial corporate stupid policy. That's it. That's right.
另一方面，我在一个家里长大，戴夫所说的是非常明智的。所以他所说的是非常具体的。我妈妈在 41 岁时上了她的第一门社区大学课程，这仅仅是因为我想获得一些培训和教育，这样我就可以去赚更多的钱，她发现了一个全新的世界，所以她在 63 岁时获得了博士学位，并在 57 岁时获得了终身教授职位，在 63 岁时成为教授。那甚至不在她的雷达上，甚至不在她的星球上。而这位来自德克萨斯州的女性，在 70 多岁时在海外牛津大学任教。这给了她一个全新的世界，但追求，戴夫在这里是对的，是她想成长自己，她想不断学习，不断变得更好。它不是由一个虚假的企业愚蠢政策驱动的。就是这样。没错。
Initially, I want to get some training so I can get a job at a community college, and that led to another thing, led to another thing, but it was all based on, I want to continue to grow. She spent time in corporations because she kept learning new things. And so if you do take this track, which I like Dave's support, make sure you study something that you're super interested in. Make sure you get there, get through it quickly too, and you find the least expensive option for you. And you pay cash for it. And if this job goes away, you've got a tool set that your horizons, your toolkit, everything's been expanded so that you can go do other things besides just this one thing. Because they set you up for this.
最初，我想获得一些培训，这样我就可以在社区大学找到一份工作，这导致了另一件事，导致了另一件事，但这一切都是基于，我想继续成长。她在企业里花了一些时间，因为她不断学习新事物。所以如果你确实走这条路，我喜欢戴夫的支持，确保你学习一些你非常感兴趣的东西。确保你到达那里，也快速完成它，并为你找到最便宜的选项。而且你用现金支付。如果这份工作消失了，你拥有一套工具，你的视野、你的工具包、一切都得到了扩展，这样你就可以去做除了这一件事之外的其他事情。因为他们为你设置了这个。
Yeah. And by the way, your tool set may tell you to leave. That's exactly right. You might find out, oh my gosh, I have the skill set to go do the same thing at a warehouse instead of a cafeteria. Then I'm not to work for stupid people. And I can make quarter million dollars doing that, right? Because you've got such amazing experience. You've got experience working with parents, working with administrators, working with legislatures, working with vendors. You've got so much experience that you may not even realize how marketable you are. That, yeah, that's great. But, Dave, I just get frustrated by those hard stops.
是的。顺便说一句，你的工具集可能会告诉你离开。完全正确。你可能会发现，天哪，我有技能去仓库做同样的事情，而不是自助餐厅。那么我就不必为愚蠢的人工作了。而且我可以赚 25 万美元做那个，对吧？因为你有如此惊人的经验。你有与家长、行政人员、立法机构、供应商合作的经验。你有太多的经验，你可能甚至没有意识到你有多大的市场价值。那，是的，那太棒了。但是，戴夫，我只是对那些硬性停止感到沮丧。
You know what I mean? Yeah. I mean, I can understand the concept, but I think in almost never in front of it, and then she's the exception, would be much. less corporate stupidity. It's just, it's just, it's just this corporate idea of, you just box yourself into a corner. Yeah. Unnecessarily, right? Well, I mean, and this is why small businesses employ 57% of Americans.
你知道我的意思吗？是的。我的意思是，我可以理解这个概念，但我认为在它前面加上“几乎从不”，然后她是例外，会少得多。企业愚蠢。这只是，这只是，这只是这种企业想法，你只是把自己逼进了一个角落。是的。不必要地，对吧？嗯，我的意思是，这就是为什么小企业雇佣了 57% 的美国人。
Because small businesses use common sense. I need the person who can do this job. Yeah. If you work for a family business, they actually, most of the time, have some brains. You know, at least look at something through a reasonable lens. You know, you might not agree with it. but they at least are, you know, it's not a blind. And is the reasonable ins can you do this job well?
因为小企业使用常识。我需要能做这份工作的人。是的。如果你为家族企业工作，他们实际上，大多数时候，有一些大脑。你知道，至少通过合理的镜头看一些东西。你知道，你可能不同意它。但他们至少是，你知道，这不是盲目的。合理的镜头是你能做好这份工作吗？
Yeah. With excellence? Yeah. I don't know what anyone's degree is in this place, except yours because you talk about them all the time. If you're shopping online and these days, everybody does, data brokers are out there right now buying and selling your personal information, your phone number, your home address, your email,
是的。卓越地？是的。我不知道这个地方任何人的学位是什么，除了你的，因为你一直在谈论它们。如果你在网上购物，这些天，每个人都这样做，数据经纪人现在就在那里买卖你的个人信息、你的电话号码、你的家庭住址、你的电子邮件，
without your knowledge or consent. And that puts you at risk for spam calls, scam texts, and fraud. Combined with AI, those scams are getting more sophisticated every day. And trying to get it under control yourself is basically impossible unless you have Delete Me. Delete Me goes to hundreds of these creepy data broker sites, finds your info and removes it, and you never have to lift a finger. Plus, they keep monitoring for it and removing it if and when it pops up again.
在没有你的知情或同意的情况下。这让你面临垃圾电话、诈骗短信和欺诈的风险。结合人工智能，这些诈骗每天都在变得更加复杂。而且除非你有 Delete Me，否则你自己控制它基本上是不可能的。Delete Me 会访问数百个这些令人毛骨悚然的数据经纪人网站，找到你的信息并将其删除，你永远不必动一根手指。此外，他们会持续监控它，并在它再次出现时将其删除。
You don't have to remove your own info every time it pops up like some unwinnable game of whack-a-mole. I personally use and love Delete Me, and my scamy texts and spammy calls have gone way down. Trust Delete Me to smackdown data brokers and protect your personal info so the game of whackamole can finally stop. Go to join delete me.com slash Ramsey and you'll get 20% off an annual plan. That's join, J-O-I-N, deleteme.com slash Ramsey or click the link in the description. Welcome back to the Ramsey show in the Fair Winds Credit Union Studio. Manny is in Atlanta, Georgia. Hi, Manny.
你不必每次它出现时都像玩打地鼠游戏一样删除你自己的信息。我个人使用并喜欢 Delete Me，我的诈骗短信和垃圾电话已经大大减少。信任 Delete Me 来打击数据经纪人并保护你的个人信息，这样打地鼠游戏终于可以停止了。前往 join deleteme.com 斜杠 Ramsey，你将获得年度计划 20% 的折扣。那是 join, J-O-I-N, deleteme.com 斜杠 Ramsey 或点击描述中的链接。欢迎回到拉姆齐秀，在 Fair Winds Credit Union 工作室。曼尼在佐治亚州亚特兰大。你好，曼尼。
How are you? Good. How are you? Better than I deserve. What's up? Hey, so I got a rental property that's worth 600,000, well, it's estimated between 575 and 600. I owe $3.40 on it. And I have $30,000 in personal debt and $20,000 in business debt. I'm coming up on a bonus next year that I should be able to wipe out all the debt
你好吗？好。你呢？比我应得的要好。怎么了？嘿，所以我有一处出租房产，价值 60 万，嗯，估计在 57.5 万到 60 万之间。我欠它 34 万。我有 3 万的个人债务和 2 万的商业债务。明年我快要拿到奖金了，我应该能够还清所有债务
I'm trying to this you know but I'm filling a little pressure and I'm not sure if I should sell that rental to pay off the debt What do you owe to? I just kind of hold it out. What do you owe on your home? My home I owe 200.
我正在尝试这个，你知道，但我感到有点压力，我不确定我是否应该卖掉那个出租房来还清债务。你欠什么？我只是把它拿出来。你欠你的房子多少钱？我的房子我欠 20 万。
Okay. Just under $199, I think. Okay, cool. So you have a business debt, but you get a bonus. Sounds like you're an employee. How do you have both? I have a business I purchased last year, and I also have a full-time job. Oh, okay. So your business that you bought is got the $30,000, and it's a side hustle. I have $30,000 in personal debt, and then I have $20,000. 20,000. Oh, 20,000 on business.
好的。不到 19.9 万，我想。好的，酷。所以你有商业债务，但你得到了奖金。听起来你是一名员工。你怎么会有两者？我去年买了一家企业，我也有一份全职工作。哦，好的。所以你买的企业有 3 万，这是一个副业。我有 3 万的个人债务，然后我有 2 万。2 万。哦，2 万的商业债务。
Okay, so what kind of business debt? What do you owe them business debt on? Who do you owe it to? Okay. It's not business debt. It's personal. You allocated it in your mind to business, but the bank doesn't know its business. It's in your name.
好的，那么什么样的商业债务？你欠他们什么商业债务？你欠谁的？好的。这不是商业债务。这是个人的。你在心里把它分配给了商业，但银行不知道它是商业的。它在你的名下。
Yeah. So you have $20,000 of credit card debt because you used a credit card to buy a business. Okay. All right. And then $30,000 worth of other personal debt in addition to that. So there's no such thing as business. debt on something like this because banks don't loan money to businesses your size. They loan money to people that do things like business is your size, which is fine.
是的。所以你有 2 万的信用卡债务，因为你用信用卡买了一家企业。好的。好的。除了那个之外，还有 3 万的其他个人债务。所以像这样的东西没有所谓的商业债务，因为银行不会借钱给你们这种规模的企业。他们借钱给做像你们这种规模生意的人，这很好。
Okay, so anyway, minor detail. Now, so $250,000 gets you out of debt 100%, and you make what a year again? I make 60 a year, but then I get paid a bonus based on the revenue that the business that I work for does. Another 50. It's based on the revenue. So, like, this year, the bonus is projected to be $100,000, and I get paid at first quarter of the year and third quarter. Wow.
好的，所以无论如何，小细节。现在，所以 25 万让你 100% 摆脱债务，你一年又赚多少钱？我一年赚 6 万，但我会根据我工作的企业产生的收入获得奖金。另外 5 万。它是基于收入的。所以，比如，今年，奖金预计为 10 万美元，我在第一季度和第三季度获得报酬。哇。
And so next year, I would get paid about $50,000 in January, and then the other $50,000 in July. Okay. All right. So the premise that we're using to answer your question overall, you've asked a very nuanced tactical question. but the principle is that what we have found in 35 years of doing this is and proven it, by the way, is the fastest method to build wealth is to not have debt because your most powerful wealth building tool is your income. And when you give it to a stupid bank, it keeps you from building wealth. And so what I'm always going to lead you towards is being debt free as soon as possible.
所以明年，我会在一月获得大约 5 万美元，然后在七月获得另外 5 万美元。好的。好的。所以我们用来回答你问题的总体前提，你问了一个非常微妙的战术问题。但原则是，我们在做这件事的 35 年里发现的，顺便说一句，已经证明了，建立财富的最快方法是不负债，因为你最强大的财富建立工具是你的收入。当你把它交给一家愚蠢的银行时，它会阻止你建立财富。所以我总是会引导你尽快摆脱债务。
the $50,000 in miscellaneous debt, the $200,000 mortgage, and the rental. And so I love rental properties, and you're making money, and you're making good money, and you're making it in kind of a weird way, which is fun because it makes you live on the 60, and then gives you 100 to do something else with. It sounds like, are you married? Yes. What does she make? Well, she works in the business.
5 万的杂项债务，20 万的抵押贷款，以及出租房。所以我喜欢出租房产，你正在赚钱，你赚得不错，而且你以一种奇怪的方式赚钱，这很有趣，因为它让你靠 6 万生活，然后给你 10 万去做其他事情。听起来，你结婚了吗？是的。她赚多少钱？嗯，她在企业工作。
Okay. What's the business make a year? Well, we just bought it, so this is our second year. Well, you didn't pay money for a business that doesn't make money, did you? Well, we did. Yes, we did. It does make money, but we've just invested it back into the business. Okay, so what's the profit on the business a year?
好的。企业一年赚多少钱？嗯，我们刚买它，所以这是我们的第二年。嗯，你没有花钱买一家不赚钱的企业，对吧？嗯，我们买了。是的，我们买了。它确实赚钱，但我们只是把它重新投资到企业里。好的，那么企业一年的利润是多少？
Last year the business made it was just under 60,000. Okay. That you paid taxes on? Yes. Okay. Okay. And so good. Thank goodness.
去年企业赚了不到 6 万。好的。你交税了吗？是的。好的。好的。所以很好。谢天谢地。
What did you buy it for? $200,000. Okay. But you paid cash for all of it but 20? No. So I'm sorry. I messed up on that. So I have it seller financed.
你花多少钱买的？20 万。好的。但你付了现金，除了 2 万？不。所以很抱歉。我搞错了。所以我让卖家融资了。
Oh, so there's more debt. Okay. How much do you owe the seller? Right now it's about $60,000 that's left. Okay. All right. Yes, sell the rental property and pay off the $60,000 and pay off the $50,000 and pay off your home mortgage. And then you're 100% debt-free and you're making $250,000 a year pretty soon.
哦，所以还有更多债务。好的。你欠卖家多少钱？现在还剩下大约 6 万。好的。好的。是的，卖掉出租房产，还清 6 万，还清 5 万，还清你的房屋抵押贷款。然后你就 100% 无债一身轻，而且你很快一年就能赚 25 万美元。
and you're able to cash and invest and invest and buy another rental property later on for cash if you want. But I'm going to use this rental property to clean up this mess right now. Okay. Think about this from that. How would you – what business decisions would you make that are different? And how would you walk and talk inside your office with your employer if you had no mortgage, no credit card, no debt, no seller financing, zero debt in. your life. Can you breathe that level of peace into your lungs? Oh, it's so really good. Yeah. That's worth trading the rental property for. Okay. So you wouldn't wait, because I could pay off.
而且你能够现金投资，投资，以后如果想的话，用现金买另一处出租房产。但我现在要用这处出租房产来清理这个烂摊子。好的。从那个角度思考。你会——你会做出什么不同的商业决策？如果你没有抵押贷款、没有信用卡、没有债务、没有卖家融资，生活中零债务，你会如何在办公室里与你的雇主走动和交谈。你能把那种平静吸进你的肺里吗？哦，这真的很好。是的。这值得用出租房产来交换。好的。所以你不会等，因为我可以还清。
I know. I heard you. You can't pay at all. You just kept stacking debt in the conversation. For a minute, your bonus was going to handle it. But then after we finish the conversation, your bonus doesn't even come close anymore. How much do you cash flow on this rental property? $1,100. Yeah. So put it this way. the 11th you're paying more than 1100 in payments yes and this 100,000 you're going to clear all your debts off and if you get this hundred thousand dollar bonus and it all comes through as you think it's going to just that's eight years what nine years of rental of cash flow on this property yeah yeah you just accelerated that exactly right so pocket that be happy put that hundred grand towards the life you and your wife want to live in investments and what I mean you'll have no payments you'll do whatever you'll do whatever you want to want with the $100,000. Go become a multi-millionaire now with no debt payments and a great income and a good business and a good job. And by the way, you can do this two ways emotionally. You can think you're quote unquote losing this rental house or you can think, think God, I have this thing
我知道。我听到了。你不能全部还清。你在谈话中一直在堆积债务。有一分钟，你的奖金要处理它。但后来在我们结束谈话后，你的奖金甚至不再接近了。你从这处出租房产中获得多少现金流？1100 美元。是的。所以这样说吧。1100 你支付的款项超过 1100，是的，这 10 万你将清偿所有债务，如果你得到这 10 万美元奖金，并且一切都如你所想的那样实现，那只是八年，九年的房产现金流，是的，你刚刚加速了这一点，完全正确。所以把那个装进口袋，开心点，把那 10 万美元投入到你和你妻子想要过的生活中，投资，我的意思是，你将没有任何付款，你将用 10 万美元做任何你想做的事。现在成为千万富翁，没有债务付款，收入丰厚，生意好，工作好。顺便说一句，你可以在情感上以两种方式做到这一点。你可以认为你所谓的“失去”了这个出租房，或者你可以认为，感谢上帝，我有这个东西
that can clear up all of these goofy decisions I've made up until now and let me do a hard reset and we've learned our lesson. We're never going to borrow money again. We're going to have a hundred grand cash in the bank on top of what we already, my salary, we were able to just do a control delete. That's an amazing place to be. Be really grateful that you're in this position. Yeah. Go sell that house. It's wonderful. Yeah. That's exactly what I would do. And if you want to own real estate to start stacking some of your bonuses in just, you know, in a high yield savings and look over there and go, oh, there's 400,000 over there. Let's go buy a rental house. If you want to do that, that's okay. But that's three years out.
可以清理我到目前为止所做的所有愚蠢决定，让我进行硬重置，我们已经吸取了教训。我们再也不会借钱了。我们将在银行里有 10 万现金，加上我们已经有的，我的薪水，我们能够进行控制删除。那是一个令人惊叹的地方。对你处于这个位置感到非常感激。是的。去卖掉那所房子。这太棒了。是的。这正是我会做的。如果你想拥有房地产，开始堆积你的一些奖金，只是，你知道，在高收益储蓄中，看看那边，去，哦，那边有 40 万。让我们去买一栋出租房。如果你想那样做，那没关系。但那是三年后的事。
Hey guys, George Camel here. You ever feel like you make good money and still have nothing to show for it? You run into Target for one thing and somehow walk out $87 later with toothpaste and emotional support candles. Just me? Okay. Well, that's the problem. Most people don't pay attention to how they spend their money. So it does whatever it wants. And that's why we created every dollar.
嘿伙计们，我是乔治·卡梅尔。你有没有觉得你赚了很多钱，却仍然一无所有？你跑进 Target 买一样东西，不知怎么地，87 美元后走出来，带着牙膏和情感支持蜡烛。只有我吗？好的。嗯，这就是问题所在。大多数人不注意他们如何花钱。所以它想做什么就做什么。这就是我们创建 Every Dollar 的原因。
It's a budgeting app that helps you create a simple plan for your money. Every dollar's simple, it's clear, and it helps track where your money's actually going. Plus, you get daily lessons, to-dos, and reminders along the way. It's like having a money coach in your pocket. Your money's been freelancing long enough. It's time to give every dollar a full-time job. Go download every dollar for free on the app store or Google Play. Are you sick and tired of working so hard and having nothing to show for it?
这是一个预算应用程序，可以帮助你为你的钱制定一个简单的计划。Every Dollar 简单、清晰，并且有助于跟踪你的钱实际上去了哪里。此外，你还可以获得每日课程、待办事项和提醒。就像口袋里有一个理财教练。你的钱已经自由职业够久了。是时候给每一美元一份全职工作了。去 App Store 或 Google Play 免费下载 Every Dollar。你是否厌倦了如此努力工作却一无所有？
Well, that's kind of normal, but normal's broke. You don't want to be normal. You do not have to live that way. Our every dollar budgeting app helps you find extra money every month and build you a personalized Ramsey plan to beat debt, Bill wealth, follow the baby steps. In just 15 minutes, when you first start doing a budget, this always happens. You're going to find thousands of dollars. You're going to feel like you've got to raise.
嗯，这很正常，但正常是破产。你不想变得正常。你不需要那样生活。我们的 Every Dollar 预算应用程序可以帮助你每月找到额外的钱，并为你建立一个个性化的拉姆齐计划来战胜债务、建立财富、遵循婴儿步骤。在短短 15 分钟内，当你第一次开始做预算时，这总是会发生。你会发现数千美元。你会觉得你加薪了。
Hidden margin. Don't live normal when you can live like no one else. Start every dollar for free in the app store or Google Play. Kayla is in Des Moines. Hi, Kayla. How are you? Good. How are you?
隐藏的利润。不要过正常的生活，当你能过得与众不同时。在 App Store 或 Google Play 免费开始 Every Dollar。凯拉在得梅因。你好，凯拉。你好吗？好。你呢？
Better than I deserve. What's up? So I'm calling me, I was in Baby Step 7, my husband and I, when we were 27 years old, we had a paid off mortgage, no debt, and in the last 10 years, we have just backslid. And I really don't have a good excuse for it other than it was just keeping up with the Joneses. And currently we're living in a house where our monthly income is where our mortgage is about 33% of our monthly income. And we just feel so overwhelmed every every month at the end of the month for financially that I was just
比我应得的要好。怎么了？所以我打电话给我，我处于婴儿步骤 7，我和我丈夫，当我们 27 岁时，我们有付清的抵押贷款，没有债务，在过去的 10 年里，我们只是倒退了。我真的没有很好的借口，除了它只是为了跟上琼斯一家。目前我们住在一所房子里，我们的月收入是我们的抵押贷款大约占我们月收入的 33%。我们每个月月底在经济上都感到如此不知所措，以至于我只是
wondering if you think I should sell my house and downsides to something cheaper. Wow. I hear the pain of regret in your voice. Feels dirty, doesn't it? Yeah, it really just feels like we had it all figured out and now we're just normal. Oh, you just got lazy. You got relaxed and then went back. to being like everybody else. I'm so sorry.
想知道你是否认为我应该卖掉房子，换成便宜点的房子，有什么坏处吗？哇。我听出了你声音里的悔恨。感觉很糟糕，对吧？是的，感觉就像我们本来一切都安排好了，现在却变得和普通人一样了。哦，你只是变懒了。你放松了警惕，然后又变回了和大家一样。我很抱歉。
How old are you can? That's a horrible feeling. Yeah, so I'm 37, and in the last three years, we have bought and sold three separate houses, and that's really where my apprehension comes in from selling my house. Why? Just, I guess, just lifestyle creeps, just wanting bigger and better all the time. You moved up every time? Yes. Kayla, I want to tell me if I'm wrong.
你多大了？那是一种可怕的感觉。是的，我今年37岁，在过去三年里，我们买卖了三套不同的房子，这就是我担心卖房的原因。为什么？只是，我想，只是生活方式的膨胀，总是想要更大更好的东西。你每次都换了更好的房子吗？是的。凯拉，我想让你告诉我我是否错了。
I want to push on this a little bit. There is an unsettledness in your marriage. Fair? Financially, definitely. And maybe it's just financially, but there's something that y'all are chasing that over here we're going to finally feel a certain way, and then we need to go over here, and this will make us whole, and this will bring us.
我想深入探讨一下这个问题。你们的婚姻中存在一种不安感。对吗？经济上绝对是。也许只是经济上的，但你们在追求某种东西，觉得到了那边我们最终会感觉好一点，然后我们需要去那边，这会让我们完整，这会带给我们。
Like there's a, there's something that, a disconnection between, you and your spouse that is, y'all are chasing with these other things. You're looking for love in all the wrong places. Yeah. Am I off my rocker? I have a pretty happy marriage. Okay. I mean, I don't, I just, I do feel like we're chasing something, and it's more just the, you know, trying to keep up with a gentleman.
就像你们夫妻之间存在某种脱节，你们正在用这些外在的东西来弥补。你在错误的地方寻找爱。是的。我疯了吗？我的婚姻很幸福。好吧。我的意思是，我确实觉得我们在追求什么，更多的是，你知道，试图跟上别人的步伐。
I'll be happy when. I'll be happy when. I'll be happy when. Well, and you can have a happy marriage that's not a united one. you can have discontented yeah one or both of you can be peacekeepers and you all can find yourself
等我……我就幸福了。等我……我就幸福了。等我……我就幸福了。嗯，你可以拥有幸福的婚姻，但不是团结的婚姻。你们可以心怀不满，是的，你们中的一个或两个可能是和平维护者，你们可能会发现自己
sitting six inches away from each other on the couch but y'all are 6,000 miles from each other you all are in different planets and y'all can say no we're happy we don't yell we don't scream we like each other but that's different than being we are unified building a thing together and building this thing has costs and it has winds associated with it right but all I'll let to say is
坐在沙发上相隔六英寸，但你们的心却相隔六千英里。你们在不同的星球上，你们可以说“不，我们很幸福，我们不吵架，我们不尖叫，我们喜欢对方”，但这与我们团结一致、共同建设某样东西是不同的。建设这个东西有代价，也有收获，对吧？但我只想说
yeah I'll let Dave answer the question. It just sounds like, I agree, it sounds like there's, like discontentment has been driving this. And so, and contentment is a spiritual decision. Godliness with contentment is great gain to be able to just sit and breathe and call where I am okay. And we're not going to die from where we're going to work to be better. We're going to be ambitious, but we can also be content. We're being ambitious for a thing. Now, the difference is, is that we're not chasing happiness in a wrong location. Like it'll all be okay when.
是的，我让戴夫来回答这个问题。我同意，听起来确实是某种不满在驱动这一切。知足是一种精神上的决定。敬虔加上知足是大获益处，能够坐下来呼吸，并对自己所处的位置感到满意。我们不会因为现在的工作而死，我们会努力变得更好。我们会雄心勃勃，但我们也可以知足。我们是为了某样东西而雄心勃勃。现在的区别在于，我们没有在错误的地方追求幸福。比如，等……一切都会好起来的。
I'll be happy if I got this. I'll be happy if I did that. I'd be happy if I had a better car. I'd be happy if the kids were in that school district. I'd be happy if we had a white kitchen, you know, or whatever, which might have been set at my house a few years ago. So, but yeah. And what you found at every new house y'all bought, y'all went with you, right?
如果我得到了这个，我就会幸福。如果我做了那个，我就会幸福。如果我有一辆更好的车，我就会幸福。如果孩子们在那个学区，我就会幸福。如果我们有一个白色的厨房，你知道，或者其他什么，这可能是我几年前在我家说的话。所以，是的。而且你在买的每一套新房子里发现的，你们都带上了自己，对吧？
So I want you to get under the hood on this. You and your husband sit down and start talking about it. Okay. What were we chasing? that caused us to make these decisions. And I don't want to make a new decision using that same chase. That's exactly right. I want to make a new decision based on math and does it take us towards our new goal.
所以我希望你能深入了解这一点。你和你丈夫坐下来谈谈。好吧。我们到底在追求什么，导致我们做出这些决定？我不想用同样的追求去做出新的决定。完全正确。我想根据数学做出新的决定，看看它是否能带我们实现新的目标。
Because yes, because you've run towards a different house, a quote unquote upgrading house for the last three years. You're still going to be running. You might be running a different direction, but you're still just running from something. instead of saying, hey, I love that, the diagnosis of our problem, if we just say, what have we been chasing and who do we want to be? How do we want our, wherever we live, a one-bedroom apartment or a really fancy house, how do I want this house to feel? And, man, begin to reverse engineer the action steps we're going to take so that we can get to this warmth and joy and laughter. What do we want our life to feel like? It's a really heartfelt, authentic question. It's a great question. I love it. I appreciate you being vulnerable about it. and letting us jump on this problem with you. Yeah, so this is what drives a lot of stuff. I mean, sometimes I'm asked, you know, what's the most powerful financial principle?
因为是的，因为你在过去三年里一直奔向不同的房子，所谓的“升级”房子。你仍然会继续奔跑。你可能是在朝着不同的方向奔跑，但你仍然只是在逃避什么。而不是说，嘿，我喜欢这个，对我们问题的诊断，如果我们只是说，我们一直在追求什么？我们想成为什么样的人？无论我们住在哪里，是一居室公寓还是非常豪华的房子，我希望这个房子感觉如何？伙计，开始反向设计我们要采取的行动步骤，这样我们才能获得这种温暖、快乐和欢笑。我们希望我们的生活感觉如何？这是一个非常真诚、真实的问题。这是一个很好的问题。我喜欢它。我很感激你对此表现出的脆弱，并让我们和你一起解决这个问题。是的，这就是驱动很多事情的原因。我的意思是，有时有人问我，你知道，最强大的财务原则是什么？
Contentment. Because when you're content, you don't go in debt to buy something you can't afford. When you're content, you can live on less than you make. When you're content, you can be generous. When you're content, you can invest and save because you don't have to consume all of it. Who was Warren Buffett's right hand man? Charlie.
知足。因为当你知足时，你不会为了买你买不起的东西而负债。当你知足时，你可以量入为出。当你知足时，你可以慷慨大方。当你知足时，你可以投资和储蓄，因为你不必把所有钱都消费掉。沃伦·巴菲特的得力助手是谁？查理。
Yeah, man, he has some great one-liners about, like, my watch costs $30 and it tells the same time your watch does, right? Like, just some, if you can learn to settle in here and just drop your shoulders, man, you kind of, you become so free you can do whatever you want because you're not subject to the whims of other people's approval. It's strange, though. I mean, part of contentment is, is I don't care what anybody thinks. Yeah.
是的，伙计，他有一些很棒的妙语，比如，我的手表花了30美元，它报的时间和你的一样，对吧？就像，如果你能学会在这里安顿下来，放下你的肩膀，伙计，你会变得非常自由，你可以做任何你想做的事，因为你不受别人认可的摆布。不过，这很奇怪。我的意思是，知足的一部分是，我不在乎别人怎么想。是的。
Which we always find that statement. among millionaires. I became, I got out of debt and I became wealthy when I quit caring what others think. Why do you drive a Toyota and you're worth $4 million? I don't care. Why do you? I'm not taking a pole. Yeah.
我们总是在百万富翁中发现这种说法。我摆脱了债务，变得富有，是因为我不再在乎别人怎么想。你为什么开丰田车，而你身价400万美元？我不在乎。你为什么？我不是在做民意调查。是的。
Why do you wear those shoes? At a stoplight from people I don't even know. Because I don't care. Yeah. Yeah. But it's, Dave, I think people hear this as, for lack of better terms, oppressive speech. This is the most empowering thing you could tell somebody is, unhook yourself from all of these phantom judgments that you think are being cast your way.
你为什么穿那双鞋？在红绿灯前，面对我甚至不认识的人。因为我不在乎。是的。是的。但是，戴夫，我认为人们把这听作是，用缺乏更好的词来说，压迫性的言论。这是你能告诉某人的最赋能的话，就是，把自己从你认为别人强加给你的所有幻觉判断中解脱出来。
and get in the driver's seat of your own life, become the chief agent in where you and your spouse want to go, man, you become, you can just do anything. Yeah. And it's pretty extraordinary. We had a relative when we got hardcore. After the bankruptcy, we got hardcore. And we still are. We never quit. Yeah.
坐上你自己生活的驾驶座，成为你和你配偶想要去的地方的首席代理人，伙计，你变得，你可以做任何事。是的。这非常了不起。当我们变得强硬时，我们有一位亲戚。破产后，我们变得强硬了。我们现在仍然如此。我们从未放弃。是的。
We don't borrow money for anything ever. And we don't care what you think. period. Now, I'll try to convince you for your sake, if you're asking me a question, that's what I do here on the air. But in terms of, do I need your approval to become as wealthy as we have become by not borrowing money? No, I don't need your approval. Not at all. I'm not taking a poll. And then we had a relative that's like, yeah, I'm worried about y'all. I think I had bankruptcy damaged you. I think you need counseling. And I'm like, for sure, but not for the reasons you think. And so we took her on a cruise a few years later.
我们从不为任何事情借钱。我们不在乎你怎么想。句号。现在，如果你问我问题，我会为了你的利益试图说服你，这就是我在节目中所做的。但就，我需要你的认可才能通过不借钱变得像我们现在这么富有吗？不，我不需要你的认可。一点也不。我没有在做民意调查。然后我们有一位亲戚说，是的，我为你们担心。我想破产伤害了你们。我想你需要咨询。我说，当然，但不是因为你认为的原因。所以几年后我们带她去游轮旅行。
Well, just to say thanks for her advice. There was full of crap. But yeah. I think you need counseling. I think you've joined a cult. Is that church you're going to a cult? Church lady, right? Yeah.
嗯，只是为了感谢她的建议。那是满口胡言。但是的。我想你需要咨询。我想你加入了邪教。你去的那家教堂是邪教吗？教堂女士，对吧？是的。
Thank you, Dana Carvey. But if you find yourself running and you're running from thing to thing to thing. That's so good, Kayla. Thank you. You got us off on this. Yeah. The most helpful thing you can do sometimes is just stop. running. Why? What am I running? Why am I in this race? Yeah. It's they call it the rat race. Yeah,
谢谢你，达纳·卡维。但如果你发现自己在奔跑，而且你是在从一件事跑到另一件事。太好了，凯拉。谢谢你。你让我们谈到了这个。是的。有时你能做的最有帮助的事情就是停止。奔跑。为什么？我在跑什么？我为什么要参加这场比赛？是的。他们称之为“老鼠赛跑”。是的，
the, man, I just, I was telling you off air. They don't call it the thoroughbrage race. They call it rats. A powerful book by Ty Wynn. He's a professor in the University of Utah called The Score, but he asked this really important question in the book, is this the game I want to be playing. That's it. And man, that question is, I asked myself that 10 times a day now. I'm going to take my marbles and go home. Thank you. Somebody cuts me off and traw me off and track. and I feel that is this a game I want to play? No. Right?
伙计，我刚才在节目外告诉你。他们不叫它纯种马比赛。他们叫它老鼠。泰·温教授在犹他大学写了一本很有影响力的书，叫《得分》，他在书中问了一个非常重要的问题：这是我想玩的游戏吗？就是这样。伙计，我现在每天问自己这个问题10次。我要带着我的弹珠回家了。谢谢。有人切断了我的路，让我偏离了轨道。我感觉到了，这是我想玩的游戏吗？不。对吧？
To, like, all of it. Is this the hill you really want to die? Is this it? No, man. That's so good. I want joy in my house. That's what I want. All right, let's cut to the chase.
对于，就像，这一切。这是你真正想死的山头吗？就是这个吗？不，伙计。太好了。我想要我的房子里有快乐。这就是我想要的。好吧，让我们切入正题。
It's easy to get discouraged about crazy house prices and interest rates. But when you have the right real estate agent to help you buy and sell the right way, you'll have confidence to make smart decisions. Ramsey trusted agents aren't just experts who guide you through buying or selling. They're people you can. can trust to have your back from the first call to closing day. Find a Ramsey trusted agent near you at Ramsey Solutions.com slash agent. That's Ramsey Solutions.com slash a...
面对疯狂的房价和利率，很容易感到沮丧。但当你拥有合适的房地产经纪人来帮助你以正确的方式买卖时，你就有信心做出明智的决定。Ramsey信赖的经纪人不仅仅是指导你买卖的专家。他们是你从第一次通话到成交日都可以信赖的人，他们会支持你。在RamseySolutions.com/agent找到你附近的Ramsey信赖经纪人。那是RamseySolutions.com/a...
Mark is in Buffalo, New York. Hey, Mark, how are you? I'm great, Dave. Thanks for taking my phone call. Sure. What's up? Well, I'm trying to convince my wife that for the next couple years, I'm hoping to retire in the next four to five years,
马克在纽约布法罗。嘿，马克，你好吗？我很好，戴夫。谢谢你接我的电话。当然。怎么了？嗯，我正在试图说服我的妻子，在接下来的几年里，我希望在未来四到五年内退休，
to invest in the markets instead of me. memories. I know that sounds kind of odd. She would rather spend the money, I don't want to say now, but rather spend it on the kids and grandkids making memories than leaving a legacy. Well, you should do both. I'm trying to convince her that. It's not really an angry discussion. Our discussion is mostly centered on. She likes to take our entire family on cruises. And what's your net worth? Probably about 1.2 or three.
去投资市场而不是我。回忆。我知道这听起来有点奇怪。她宁愿花钱，我不想说现在，而是宁愿花在孩子和孙辈身上创造回忆，而不是留下遗产。嗯，你应该两者兼顾。我正在试图说服她。这不是一场愤怒的讨论。我们的讨论主要集中在。她喜欢带我们全家去游轮旅行。你的净资产是多少？大概120万或130万。
Okay. And what's your household income? About 190. And what does she spend on a cruise when she takes the whole family? About 30, 35. Okay. That doesn't keep you from investing. Well, I guess in a way it doesn't.
好的。你们的家庭收入是多少？大概19万。她带全家去游轮时花多少钱？大概3万，3万5。好的。这并不会阻止你投资。嗯，我想在某种程度上它不会。
Definitely, we max out our 401. It keeps you from, well, then you're investing. Well, I'd like to put more in because I would love to leave my kids and grandkids something. I don't want to say substantial because I know that we're a millionaire. Yeah. Would your parents leave you? Thank God. I have both my parents still.
当然，我们最大限度地利用了我们的401k。这阻止了你，嗯，那你就是在投资。嗯，我想投入更多，因为我很乐意给我的孩子和孙辈留下一些东西。我不想说“可观”，因为我知道我们是百万富翁。是的。你的父母给你留下了什么？感谢上帝。我的父母都还在。
Okay. What will they leave you? $10 million? No. Okay. No. And you're going to be okay? Your kids are going to be okay.
好的。他们会给你留下什么？1000万美元？不。好的。不。你会没事的？你的孩子们会没事的。
So I should just let her have her enjoyment? No. I think you ought to both be, you ought to be investing, and you ought to let her have her enjoyment, and you have the money to do both, sir. Okay. Have you ever been successful in convincing? No. Okay.
所以我应该让她享受吗？不。我认为你们都应该，你们应该投资，你们应该让她享受，你们有钱两者兼顾，先生。好的。你曾经成功说服过吗？不。好的。
Because even the way you ask that question, it suggests y'all are sitting on opposite side of the table, you versus your wife. It's not an argument. It's mostly I really want to retire. I've owned a restaurant for almost 40 years now. My feet, legs, and hips and back are shot. Okay. And when I finally do retire, that $190,000 is not going to be coming in. Agreed.
因为即使是你问这个问题的方式，也暗示你们坐在桌子的两端，你和你妻子。这不是争论。主要是因为我真的很想退休。我拥有一家餐馆快40年了。我的脚、腿、臀部和背部都废了。好的。当我最终退休时，那19万美元就不会再进来了。同意。
Agreed. But hold on. You want me to work until I'm about 65, 66, 67, and I don't want that. Have you had that conversation? I'm in pain. Yes. I want to enjoy the rest of my life with you with the grandkids. and we don't have enough save to do that right now.
同意。但是等等。你想让我工作到65、66、67岁左右，我不想那样。你有过那样的谈话吗？我很痛苦。是的。我想和你以及孙辈们一起享受余生。我们现在没有足够的积蓄来做到这一点。
Well, you guys are old enough to remember 2008, and a small part of this, maybe a major part, is that I had a lot of hubris when I was young and put our business almost into almost a million dollars in debt to the state, the feds, purveyors, insurance, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. So she has this idea that money is fleeting and to enjoy it while you have it. And since 2008, we paid off our house.
嗯，你们年纪够大，记得2008年，这其中有一小部分，也许是很大一部分，是我年轻时太傲慢了，把我们的生意搞得欠了州政府、联邦政府、供应商、保险公司等近一百万美元的债务。所以她有一种想法，钱是转瞬即逝的，有的时候就享受它。自2008年以来，我们还清了房子。
We paid off our mortgage. We have about half a million in our 401. So climbed out of that hole by doing the Ramsey thing before we knew there was Ramsey. Yeah, good for you. Well done. We sold everything. We lived on. So how old today, did you say?
我们还清了抵押贷款。我们的401k里有大约50万。所以在我们知道Ramsey之前，通过做Ramsey的事情爬出了那个洞。是的，为你高兴。做得好。我们卖掉了一切。我们靠……生活。所以今天多大，你说？
58. Okay. All right. So I think you sit down and start having some very granular. conversations and say, okay, my back hurts, my hips hurt. I'm not doing this until I'm 67. I can't. And so what's going to happen is that if we, to the extent we spend all of the investment
58岁。好的。好吧。所以我认为你们坐下来开始进行一些非常细致的谈话，说，好吧，我的背很痛，我的臀部很痛。我不会一直做到67岁。我做不到。所以会发生的是，如果我们，在某种程度上我们花光了所有的投资
money, we're going to end up in a much reduced lifestyle from the time I retire on. And so this, so we can do some things. We can do the occasional cruise for everybody. We can still do a $30,000 thing. That's not undoable, but we can't do three of them because the other two things that are that size, I need to go on investing so that we're doing both things well. And I need you to join me emotionally in doing both of these things, having fun with the money and investing it. Instead of me feeling like I'm dragging you, kicking and screaming, and you're like a kid on the cereal while throwing a fit that you want sugary cereal right now. And I don't, you know, so I want us to be joined.
钱，从我退休开始，我们的生活水平会大大降低。所以，我们可以做一些事情。我们可以偶尔带大家去游轮旅行。我们仍然可以做3万美元的事情。那不是做不到的，但我们不能做三次，因为另外两件同样规模的事情，我需要继续投资，这样我们才能把两件事都做好。我需要你在情感上加入我，做这两件事，用钱玩得开心，同时也进行投资。而不是让我觉得我在拖着你，又踢又叫，你就像一个在麦片盒上发脾气的孩子，现在就想要含糖麦片。我不想，你知道，所以我希望我们团结一致。
And the healing from 2008 from the mistakes is in our rearview mirror. And we're joined together. And we're walking into a cool new future that's a two or three million dollar net worth in our early 60s. And while we're doing that, we're going to do some fun things too. But I'm nervous about that. So my tendency is to run honey over onto the saving only side. and your tendency is to run over to the other side. Both are actually correct, and we need to be doing both,
从2008年的错误中治愈已经在我们的后视镜里了。我们团结在一起。我们正在步入一个很酷的未来，在60岁出头时拥有200万或300万美元的净资产。当我们这样做的时候，我们也会做一些有趣的事情。但我对此感到紧张。所以我的倾向是把钱只放在储蓄一边。而你的倾向是跑到另一边。两者其实都是正确的，我们需要两者兼顾，
but we need to be unified in doing both. And, man, couldn't have said it better, and the thing I'll add is, Mark, you need a finish line because you're going to chase the word substantial. You're going to chase the word legacy. And if you don't give yourself a, I want every grand kid to get $25,000. I want my four kids to each get,
但我们需要在做这两件事上保持统一。而且，伙计，不能说得更好了，我要补充的是，马克，你需要一个终点线，因为你会去追逐“可观”这个词。你会去追逐“遗产”这个词。如果你不给自己一个，我希望每个孙辈都能得到25000美元。我希望我的四个孩子每人得到，
if you don't give yourself sums, By the way, that finish line can move, right? Let's say you sell your restaurant and you get eight times what you thought that can move, but man, you're going to be chasing an ever-moving finish line called substantial and called legacy. If you don't put some concrete ideas around that. If your grandkids and kids have got no sense, it doesn't matter if you leave my million or 10 million, and it'll be gone in four months. And you probably don't think any less of your parents.
如果你不给自己设定金额，顺便说一句，那个终点线是可以移动的，对吧？假设你卖掉了你的餐馆，你得到了你预想的八倍，那是可以移动的，但伙计，如果你不围绕它设定一些具体的想法，你就会去追逐一个不断移动的终点线，叫“可观”，叫“遗产”。如果你的孙辈和孩子没有头脑，你留下100万还是1000万都无所谓，四个月内就会花光。而且你可能不会因此而看轻你的父母。
Either. Yeah, you don't, because you don't have a obligation. Who aren't going to leave a ton of money from them. Yeah. And so, and I don't, you know, so I, you know, leaving, changing your family tree is a good goal. It's a good goal unless it drives you to do like you're incomplete if you don't do it somehow. There you go. And so that, that's what we want to avoid.
也是。是的，你不会，因为你没有义务。谁不会给他们留下大量的钱。是的。所以，而且我不想，你知道，所以，你知道，留下，改变你的家族树是一个很好的目标。这是一个很好的目标，除非它驱使你去做，好像如果你不以某种方式做到，你就是不完整的。就是这样。所以，这就是我们想要避免的。
Brian is with us. Brian is in Joplin, Missouri. Hey, Brian, what's up? Yes, sir, I'm a heavy equipment mechanic, and I was, I was needing help on this. Decision to run my business full-time or to keep working for my current employer. What's your business? I'm a mobile heavy equipment mechanic. How much are you making doing that?
布莱恩和我们在一起。布莱恩在密苏里州乔普林。嘿，布莱恩，怎么了？是的，先生，我是一名重型设备机械师，我需要在这方面寻求帮助。是全职经营我的生意，还是继续为我现在的雇主工作？你的生意是什么？我是移动重型设备机械师。你做这个赚多少钱？
About $4,000 a month. That's just in the evenings after 5.30 to about 10 or 11 o'clock at night, and then on the weekends. Good for you. And what do you make on your day job? About $5,500 a weekly, $35 an hour, doing it 60 hours a week. So you're making $20,000. a month at your day job? No, sir.
一个月大约4000美元。那只是在晚上5点半到10点或11点，以及周末。为你高兴。你白天的工作赚多少钱？每周大约5500美元，每小时35美元，每周工作60小时。所以你一个月在白天的工作中赚20000美元？不，先生。
Just $5,500 monthly. Monthly, not weekly. You said weekly. Okay. And so you got one that's doing $5,500 a month and one that's doing $4,000 a month, right? Yes, sir. And it's hard to juggle the two at the moment. Can you cut your hours back on your heavy equipment day job?
一个月只有5500美元。每月，不是每周。你说的是每周。好的。所以你有一个一个月赚5500美元的，一个一个月赚4000美元的，对吧？是的，先生。目前很难兼顾两者。你能减少你重型设备白天工作的工时吗？
That's what I currently did, the 40 hours a week, and it's still hard to balance. I hear you. Can you cut it more? I can see. I can ask them and see. I would ask my employer to let me have Fridays off. Yes, sir. That's what I'm currently doing now.
我目前就是这么做的，每周40小时，平衡起来仍然很难。我听到了。你能再减少一点吗？我可以看看。我可以问问他们看看。我会要求我的雇主让我周五休息。是的，先生。我目前就是这么做的。
I've got established customers, and I know I could double it if I ended up doing it. Well, we hope you can double it because you're getting ready to cut your pay in half when you quit. Yes, sir. That's true. So what I like to do in these situations, I want you to do this, okay? But I always say I want to pull the boat really close to the dock,
我有固定的客户，我知道如果我真的去做，我可以翻倍。嗯，我们希望你能翻倍，因为你辞职时准备把收入减半。是的，先生。那是真的。所以我喜欢在这些情况下做的是，我希望你这样做，好吗？但我总是说我希望把船拉得非常靠近码头，
so I'm not taking a leap of faith. And right now you're taking a leap of faith. Like you're going to cut $5,500 if you quit today out of your, a month. And you've got to make that up. And you're only making four now. And if you don't make it up, then you're going to fill that water when you hit it. So I'd like to say we're making six or six. seven on the business and we've cut the hours down on the day job that gets the boat closer to
这样我就不是在进行信仰的飞跃。而现在你正在进行信仰的飞跃。就像如果你今天辞职，你一个月将减少5500美元的收入。你必须补上那个缺口。而你现在只赚4000。如果你补不上，那么当你撞到水面时，你会感觉到水的。所以我喜欢说我们在生意上赚六千或六千七，并且我们减少了白天工作的工时，这让船更靠近
the dock and then you just step into the boat you don't have to jump and hope you hit it and so that's what I'm going to do I want to get your I know you're tired and you're a hardworking dude and I love what you're doing I want you to go do this I want you to go in business for yourself I'm going to send you a copy of building a business you love our book and I want you to read it Our big investing essentials event is next Tuesday and Wednesday. Don't miss your chance to be there. Investing isn't difficult, but it's not something you can learn in a 60-second TikTok video. So at this two-night virtual event, George Camel and I will walk you through my playbook for investing and wealth planning. We'll simplify everything from maximizing your 401k to reducing taxes and setting up wills and real estate and much more. Join us next week on September 1st and 2nd. Tickets start at $199. Get yours now at ramsysolutions.com slash events or by clicking the link in the show notes.
码头，然后你只需跨进船里，你不必跳跃并希望你能跳到。所以这就是我要做的，我想要得到你的，我知道你很累，你是一个勤奋的家伙，我喜欢你正在做的事情，我希望你去这样做。我希望你去做自己的生意。我会寄给你一本我们的书《建立你热爱的生意》，我希望你读一读。我们的大型投资基础活动在下周二和周三。不要错过参加的机会。投资并不困难，但这不是你在60秒的TikTok视频中就能学会的东西。所以在这个为期两晚的虚拟活动中，乔治·卡梅尔和我将带你了解我的投资和财富规划手册。我们将简化一切，从最大化你的401k到减少税收，设置遗嘱和房地产等等。下周9月1日和2日加入我们。门票199美元起。现在在ramsysolutions.com/events获取你的门票，或者点击节目说明中的链接。
Our scripture of the day, 1 Corinthians 1013, no temptation is overtaken you except what is common to mankind. And God is faithful. He will not let you be tempted beyond what you can bear. But when you are tempted, he will also provide a way out so that you can endure it. Ronald Reagan said status quo, you know, is Latin for the mess we're in. That is fantastic. That's great. I love it.
我们今天的经文，哥林多前书10:13，你们所遇见的试探，无非是人所能受的。神是信实的，他必不叫你们受试探过于所能受的。在受试探的时候，总要给你们开一条出路，叫你们能忍受得住。罗纳德·里根说现状，你知道，是拉丁语，意思是我们的混乱。这太棒了。太好了。我喜欢它。
Oliver's in Connecticut. Hey, Oliver, what's up in your world? Hey, Dave, thanks for taking my call. I love your show. Well, thank you, sir. Yes. My question, I'm 46, single, no kids, no debt. I haven't had any kind of full-time work in about a year and a half.
奥利弗在康涅狄格州。嘿，奥利弗，你的世界里怎么了？嘿，戴夫，谢谢你接我的电话。我喜欢你的节目。嗯，谢谢你，先生。是的。我的问题，我46岁，单身，没有孩子，没有债务。我大约一年半没有做任何全职工作了。
I do have some pretty good savings, and I'd like to know your opinion, if you think I may be able to retire at this point. Today? Yeah. I mean, yes, yes, not have to work again. What are you going to do with the rest of your life? Well, you know, it's funny. I actually interviewed for a part-time minimum wage job today,
我确实有一些相当不错的积蓄，我想知道你的意见，如果你认为我此时可以退休的话。今天？是的。我的意思是，是的，是的，不必再工作了。你余生要做什么？嗯，你知道，这很有趣。我今天实际上面试了一份兼职的最低工资工作，
because it has been kind of boring. I tried to get some jobs. I haven't had luck because they say you don't have the education or grad school or experience. What are you going to do with the rest of your life, Oliver? I would like to have a wife and a child, and so that's part of the question is how much. And that requires not working? Well, yeah, I mean, it may be a possibility. Again, I'm not, I can tell you my financials, and maybe you can tell me your opinion.
因为这有点无聊。我试着找一些工作。我没有运气，因为他们说你没有学历、研究生学位或经验。奥利弗，你余生要做什么？我想有一个妻子和一个孩子，所以这是问题的一部分，就是多少。这需要不工作吗？嗯，是的，我的意思是，这可能是一种可能性。再说一次，我不是，我可以告诉你我的财务状况，也许你可以告诉我你的意见。
My opinion is you shouldn't quit work at 46, regardless of your financials. You should be doing something for the good of mankind and yourself. You don't have to work on slave job. You don't have to work 40 hours or 80 hours a week or something, but you ought to be doing something. Okay, so what is your net worth? What do you have saved? I have $2.7 million in a brokerage. One million of that's in a Roth.
我的意见是，无论你的财务状况如何，你不应该在46岁时辞职。你应该为人类和你自己的利益做点什么。你不必做奴隶工作。你不必每周工作40小时或80小时，但你应该做点什么。好的，那么你的净资产是多少？你存了多少钱？我在经纪账户里有270万美元。其中100万在罗斯个人退休账户里。
those are like you suggest mutual funds and ETSs that average about 10 to 11 percent have a three-family house I own which cash full about 300 a month of 30,000 in HSA 40,000 40,000 high-yield savings account and where'd you get all that? I ran a tennis business for about 15 years and sold it no I was leased space out of an indoor tennis club, and they sold the club. I was trying to buy the club, and the owner was going to sell it to me, and then at the last minute, he said he sold it to a golf, a golf buddy. The golf buddy came in, and he said, I have new plans for the place, and you're not part of them. Okay, so you got, you lost your lease, and you just closed to the
那些就像你建议的共同基金和ETF，平均收益率约为10%到11%，我拥有一栋三户住宅，每月现金流约为300美元，HSA里有30000美元，高收益储蓄账户里有40000美元，你从哪里得到这一切的？我经营了一家网球生意大约15年，卖掉了它，不，我租了一个室内网球俱乐部的空间，他们卖掉了俱乐部。我试图买下那个俱乐部，老板本来要卖给我，然后在最后一刻，他说他把它卖给了一个高尔夫球友。那个高尔夫球友进来了，他说，我对这个地方有新的计划，你不是其中的一部分。好的，所以你失去了租约，你只是关闭了
business, but the money came from making a lot of money in the tennis business. Yeah, it was, it was, I set it up as a lot of money. Ness Corp, I had 1099 workers. But I mean, you made a profit, a lot of money, and you stacked it. That's where the money came from. That's what I'm trying to ascertain. Yeah, I live a simple life. Okay, so what does it take you to live on a year if you wanted to not work anymore?
生意，但钱来自于在网球生意中赚了很多钱。是的，它，它，我把它建立为很多钱。Ness Corp，我有1099名员工。但我的意思是，你赚了利润，很多钱，你存了起来。钱就是这么来的。这就是我试图确定的。是的，我过着简单的生活。好的，那么如果你不想再工作了，你一年需要多少钱生活？
What do you need to live on? Well, right now it's about $85,000 a year. Okay. But I rent, and I would like to buy a house. Yeah. Well, your non-roth investments should be generating more than $85,000 a year. Mm-hmm. And so, yeah, you could quit today.
你需要多少钱生活？嗯，现在大约一年85000美元。好的。但我租房，我想买房子。是的。嗯，你的非罗斯投资应该每年产生超过85000美元。嗯哼。所以，是的，你可以今天辞职。
But aside, like I said earlier, aside from the finances, I don't think you need to quit today. And you are a proven entrepreneur. You ran a very lucrative business. You developed the business model. Obviously, I love for tennis that you parlayed into whatever sources of revenue there and, you know, and stacked $3 million. Way to go. and you're only 46. So, you know, do you not remember how alive you felt when you were fighting those battles growing that business?
但除了，像我刚才说的，除了财务之外，我不认为你需要今天辞职。你是一位久经考验的企业家。你经营了一家非常赚钱的生意。你开发了商业模式。显然，我喜欢网球，你把它转化为那里的任何收入来源，你知道，并存了300万美元。做得好。而且你才46岁。所以，你知道，你不记得当你为了发展那项业务而进行那些战斗时，你感觉有多么活着吗？
It felt it did feel good, and I haven't been able to come up with any other entrepreneurial ideas. And before that business, part of working so hard was I had eight or nine jobs that were just terrible. Most of them being commissioned only dollar-for-dollar sales jobs. Okay, so don't do that. You don't have to. You got $85,000 coming off that brokerage account. So we're not stressed about where we're going to go or what we're going to do. But if you want a wife and kid, I think you're a lot more attractive if you're actually out there doing something.
感觉确实很好，我还没能想出任何其他的创业想法。在那项业务之前，努力工作的一部分是我有八九份工作，简直太糟糕了。其中大多数是纯佣金的销售工作。好的，所以不要那样做。你不必那样做。你的经纪账户里有85000美元。所以我们不担心我们要去哪里或要做什么。但如果你想要一个妻子和孩子，我认为如果你真的在外面做点什么，你会更有吸引力。
And most women don't want to marry a couch potato, even if they're independently wealthy. Yeah. And the research is pretty clear that if you, when you quit to do nothing, your body gets the message. and it will start to send the signals, we're done here. Our work is done here. And you'll see your health fall off a cliff, your emotional mental health will fall off a cliff. Your body just starts shutting it down. So I would go and do, you know, if Ramsey closed today, I'm 66, not 46, I would go and open a business because it's fun.
而且大多数女性不想嫁给一个沙发土豆，即使他们独立富有。是的。研究非常清楚，如果你，当你辞职什么都不做时，你的身体会收到这个信息。它会开始发出信号，我们在这里完成了。我们的工作在这里完成了。你会看到你的健康状况跌落悬崖，你的情绪心理健康会跌落悬崖。你的身体只是开始关闭它。所以我建议去，你知道，如果Ramsey今天关闭，我66岁，不是46岁，我会去开一家公司，因为它很有趣。
Because I enjoy, I enjoy business, I enjoy running a business, I enjoy the, the challenge. I enjoy the building of something that's profitable that the marketplace likes and gives you money for. And I'll say this. Happy customer. You are the most singularly focused business person I've ever been around who's got an obsession with helping the front line customer. Right. Like, I know you like building a business, but I think you like helping people a lot. Yeah, but that's a good business does that.
因为我享受，我享受商业，我享受经营一家公司，我享受，挑战。我享受建立某种有利可图的东西，市场喜欢它并给你钱。我会说这个。满意的客户。你是我接触过的最专注的商人，对帮助一线客户有执念。对吧。就像，我知道你喜欢建立一家公司，但我认为你非常喜欢帮助别人。是的，但那是一家好公司所做的。
That's exactly right. If you're running car repair, you better like helping people. That's exactly right. Yeah. If you're in the, if you're a doctor, a medical doctor, you should like helping people. Feel better. Yeah. So Oliver, like, what about your, did you like the tennis business?
完全正确。如果你在经营汽车修理，你最好喜欢帮助别人。完全正确。是的。如果你在，如果你是一名医生，一名医学博士，你应该喜欢帮助别人。感觉更好。是的。所以奥利弗，就像，你喜欢网球生意吗？
Because, man, go open a tennis business. Or did you like the teaching part? Or do you like seeing the light bulb come on in young kids and teenagers and taking pretty good athletes and making them helping them become excellent? Like, what about that? Did you love? Do you can do that anywhere? Yeah, exactly. All over the place.
因为，伙计，去开一家网球公司吧。或者你喜欢教学部分？或者你喜欢看到年轻孩子和青少年眼中的灯泡亮起，把相当不错的运动员变成，帮助他们变得优秀？就像，关于那个？你爱吗？你可以在任何地方做那个？是的，完全正确。到处都是。
But find a thing. And so going and interviewing for a job and them saying you don't have a degree after you made three million dollars is kind of funny. Yeah, it's absurd. The guy telling you that's making used to be your employee. Yeah, he used to hire you to teach his kid how to play tennis, right? Yeah. And so, no, that does not steal my hope and make me want to quit. Quite to the contrary.
但找到一件事。所以去面试一份工作，他们说你没有学位，在你赚了300万美元之后，这有点好笑。是的，这很荒谬。那个告诉你的人以前是你的员工。是的，他以前雇你教他的孩子怎么打网球，对吧？是的。所以，不，那不会偷走我的希望并让我想要辞职。恰恰相反。
It gives me a real reason to go start a business. It kick his butt. All right. Joey's in Grand Rapids. Hey, Joey, what's up? Hey, so I am a recovering gambling addict. today's 31 days for not gambling. Good for you.
它给了我一个真正的理由去开始一项业务。踢他的屁股。好的。乔伊在大急流城。嘿，乔伊，怎么了？嘿，我是一个正在康复的赌博成瘾者。今天是戒赌的第31天。为你高兴。
Congratulations, dude. Thank you. Way to go. What were you gambling on? Stupid apps like MGM, like on the slot machines and stuff. It's a losing game. Yeah, it is. It's a house wins.
恭喜你，伙计。谢谢。做得好。你在赌什么？愚蠢的应用程序，像MGM，像老虎机之类的东西。这是一个输的游戏。是的，它是。庄家赢。
Okay, good for you. How can we help? Thank you. Yeah, so I started budgeting in June of this year from watching you guys' show, and I've accumulated some debt from gambling. I've already paid off. I started with $28,000 in debt. I got it down to 23,911.
好的，为你高兴。我们能怎么帮你？谢谢。是的，所以我从今年6月开始通过看你们的节目进行预算，我从赌博中积累了一些债务。我已经还清了。我开始时有28000美元的债务。我把它降到了23911。
Way to go. But I'm trying to figure out how to prioritize it. List your debt, list your debt, smallest to largest. Yeah. Regardless of what kind of debt or what the interest rate is. Yeah, absolutely. Credit cards, I owe $10,115. On one card?
做得好。但我正在试图弄清楚如何优先处理它。列出你的债务，列出你的债务，从小到大。是的。无论是什么样的债务或利率是多少。是的，绝对。信用卡，我欠10115美元。在一张卡上？
No, it's four separate cards. List them individually. Okay. Smallest to largest, and pay minimum payments. on everything but the little one and attack the little one with a vengeance. Hey, we want to be part of your healing. I'm excited for your journey. We're going to send you a copy of the total money makeover, which will show you exactly
不，是四张不同的卡。分别列出它们。好的。从小到大，支付最低还款额。除了小的那张，其他的都付最低还款额，然后全力攻击小的那张。嘿，我们想成为你治愈的一部分。我为你感到兴奋。我们将寄给你一本《总金钱改造》，它会向你展示确切的
how to do all of this stuff, Joey. Way to go, man. I'm proud of you. We're also going to sign you up for every dollar, the advanced version of our budgeting app to also help you to continue this healing process. We want to be there for you and give you everything you can do. Hey, you're young guys out there. You need to take Joey's cue.
如何做所有这些事情，乔伊。做得好，伙计。我为你感到骄傲。我们还将为你注册EveryDollar，我们预算应用程序的高级版本，以帮助你继续这个治愈过程。我们想为你服务，并给你你能做的一切。嘿，你们这些年轻人。你需要听乔伊的。
fastest thing that's destroying men, young men in their 20s is sports betting. I mean, Draft Kings is not a blessing to your life. I'll just tell you. It's screwing up more of you guys than anything else we're running into. So Joey's just the tip of the iceberg. Make sure you do this stuff. Hey, guys, that's how it's done. It's common sense for your dollars and cents.
摧毁男人，20多岁的年轻男人最快的事情就是体育博彩。我的意思是，Draft Kings对你的生活不是一种祝福。我只是告诉你。它搞砸了你们这些家伙，比我们遇到的任何其他事情都多。所以乔伊只是冰山一角。确保你做这些事情。嘿，伙计们，这就是它的做法。这是你美元和美分的常识。
And, you know, grandma's advice still works. even if it's filtered through a John Deloney or Dave Ramsey. It's just a little lesson you make, man. It works 100% of the time. There it is. We'll be back with you before you know it. In the meantime, remember, there's ultimately only one way to financial peace, and that's to walk daily with the Prince of Peace.
而且，你知道，奶奶的建议仍然有效。即使它是通过约翰·德洛尼或戴夫·拉姆齐过滤的。这只是你赚的一点小教训，伙计。它100%的时间都有效。就是这样。我们很快就会回来。在此期间，记住，最终只有一种通往财务和平的方法，那就是每天与和平之君同行。
Christ Jesus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
基督耶稣。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。